programming throwdown episode 148 package management with max how take it away jason hey everybody so um if you have used any OS, which is everybody who's listening to this, even if you're on your phone, you have had to deal with installing software and managing software of various ways, shapes and forms. If you're a developer, you also have to deal with libraries, static shared libraries, all sorts of ancillary packages. And that makes package management a real challenge and a real opportunity to learn more about the OS. So we're going to kind of dive into all of that and talk about some other stuff that Max has been up to. So we'll jump right into it. We have Max Howell, who's the CEO of TXYZ and the creator of Homebrew. Thanks so much, Max, for
programming throwdown episode 148 package management with max how take it away jason hey everybody so um if you have used any OS, which is everybody who's listening to this, even if you're on your phone, you have had to deal with installing software and managing software of various ways, shapes and forms. If you're a developer, you also have to deal with libraries, static shared libraries, all sorts of ancillary packages. And that makes package management a real challenge and a real opportunity to learn more about the OS. So we're going to kind of dive into all of that and talk about some other stuff that Max has been up to. So we'll jump right into it. We have Max Howell, who's the CEO of TXYZ and the creator of Homebrew. Thanks so much, Max, for|||编程 Throwdown 第 148 期，本期节目我们邀请到了 Max Howell 来聊聊包管理。把话筒交给你，杰森。大家好，所以，嗯，如果你用过任何操作系统——听节目的各位肯定都用过，哪怕你用的是手机——你都免不了要跟安装软件以及各种形式的软件管理打交道。如果你是一名开发者，你还得处理各种库、静态动态共享库，以及形形色色的辅助包。这使得包管理既是一个真正的挑战，也是一个深入了解操作系统的绝佳机会。所以我们今天打算深入探讨这些内容，顺便聊聊 Max 最近在忙的其他事情。那我们马上开始。今天我们请到了 TXYZ 的首席执行官、Homebrew 的创作者 Max Howell。非常感谢 Max
coming on the show. It's great to be here. Cool. So one thing we kind of lead in is just talking about the whole remote revolution, which is almost like two years old now. But I think it's still kind of worth talking about, especially when folks are starting new ventures. When you started TXYZ, did you start it during the pandemic? Was it pre, post pandemic? And how are you handling remote work and return to office and all of these things? That's a good question, especially nowadays. Personally, I feel that I started remote
coming on the show. It's great to be here. Cool. So one thing we kind of lead in is just talking about the whole remote revolution, which is almost like two years old now. But I think it's still kind of worth talking about, especially when folks are starting new ventures. When you started TXYZ, did you start it during the pandemic? Was it pre, post pandemic? And how are you handling remote work and return to office and all of these things? That's a good question, especially nowadays. Personally, I feel that I started remote|||来到节目。很高兴来到这里。太好了。那么我们切入正题的第一个话题，是聊聊整个远程办公革命，这差不多已经是两年前的事了。但我觉得它依然值得讨论，尤其是当人们开始新的创业时。你创立 TXYZ 的时候，是在大流行期间吗？是之前还是之后？你是如何处理远程办公、重返办公室以及诸如此类的事情的？这确实是个好问题，尤其是现在。就我个人而言，我觉得我一开始就是远程办公的
because I started with open source. It's how I got into programming. And the first bunch of people that I worked with were all over the world. We had a bunch of people in Europe, some people in America, and some people in Australia. So for me, it was just always the natural way to work. And so when I got my first professional job in an office, I didn't like it. I liked the commute.
because I started with open source. It's how I got into programming. And the first bunch of people that I worked with were all over the world. We had a bunch of people in Europe, some people in America, and some people in Australia. So for me, it was just always the natural way to work. And so when I got my first professional job in an office, I didn't like it. I liked the commute.|||因为我是从做开源开始的。我就是通过开源进入编程领域的。我最早合作的一群人遍布世界各地。我们在欧洲有一群人，美国有一些，澳大利亚也有一些。所以对我来说，这一直都是最自然的工作方式。因此，当我得到第一份在办公室的正职工作时，我并不喜欢它。我喜欢通勤吗？
It sucked and having to get there. But, you know, certainly some great things about being in person, like some ideas only form when you're like bantering around the table. So what was your commute like? When I started working in London, I live in the US now, but this was a while ago. And I lived an hour north of London by train. Is that Chelmsford? I have an aunt in Chelmsford. I don't know. And she says that's north of London. There's probably a million places north of London, but I figured I'd throw a dart at the dartboard. Yeah, I don't know Chelmsford. This happens a lot where people are like, oh, do you know this tiny little town in Britain?
It sucked and having to get there. But, you0** know, certainly some great things about being in person, like some ideas only form when you're like bantering around the table. So what was your commute like? When I started working in London, I live in the US now, but this was a while ago. And I lived an hour north of London by train. Is that Chelmsford? I have an aunt in Chelmsford. I don't know. And she says that's north of London. There's probably a million places north of London, but I figured I'd throw a dart at the dartboard. Yeah, I don't know Chelmsford. This happens a lot where people are like, oh, do you know this tiny little town in Britain?|||那体验太糟糕了，还得赶去公司。不过呢，面对面交流确实有一些极好的地方，比如有些点子只有在大家围坐在一起开玩笑时才会产生。那你以前的通勤是怎样的？我刚开始在伦敦工作时——我现在住在美国，但那是很久以前的事了——我住在伦敦以北坐火车一小时车程的地方。那是切姆斯福德（Chelmsford）吗？我有个姑妈在切姆斯福德。我不知道。她说那是伦敦北部。伦敦以北可能有一百万个地方，但我当时觉得就像在飞镖盘上随便掷一镖。对，我不知道切姆斯福德。这种事经常发生，人们会说：“哦，你知道英国这个小镇吗？”
Actually, I probably should. I probably should know better. I lived in Milton Keynes, which is where some of my family still lives, about an hour north of London. Kind of famous city for being kind of modeled on the American model of how cities should be with lots of fast roads and big malls and things.
Actually, I probably should. I probably should know better. I lived in Milton Keynes, which is where some of my family still lives, about an hour north of London. Kind of famous city for being kind of modeled on the American model of how cities should be with lots of fast roads and big malls and things.|||其实我大概应该知道的。我其实应该更清楚一点。我住在米尔顿凯恩斯（Milton Keynes），我的一些家人现在还住在那儿，在伦敦以北大约一小时车程的地方。这是一座挺有名的城市，因为它有点仿照美国城市的模式建造，拥有许多快车道和大商场之类的东西。
And so I liked it for that. I've been to Melton Mowbray, which is completely the opposite. Melton Mowbray, I think they're famous for growing honey. And it was very rural, which I think is like a nice break if you've been in urban towns for a while. Melton Mowbray is famous for their pork pies in fact oh oh i didn't know that yeah they're delicious and uh one of the things i miss most i think there's i think i say there's like three things i miss from britain and uh pork pies is one they all begin to be i miss pork pies
And so I liked it for that. I've been to Melton Mowbray, which is completely the opposite. Melton Mowbray, I think they're famous for growing honey. And it was very rural, which I think is like a nice break if you've been in urban towns for a while. Melton Mowbray is famous for their pork pies in fact oh oh i didn't know that yeah they're delicious and uh one of the things i miss most i think there's i think i say there's like three things i miss from britain and uh pork pies is one they all begin to be i miss pork pies|||所以我挺喜欢那里的。我去过梅尔顿莫布雷（Melton Mowbray），那里完全是另一回事。梅尔顿莫布雷，我觉得他们以产蜂蜜闻名。那里非常乡村化，如果你在城市里待了一段时间，我觉得这算是一个很好的放松。事实上，梅尔顿莫布雷以其猪肉馅饼而闻名。哦，哦，我不知道这个。对，它们非常美味。而且，嗯，这是我最想念的东西之一。我想说，大概有三样东西是我从英国回来后一直怀念的，嗯，猪肉馅饼就是其中之一。它们都开始……我太想念猪肉馅饼了。
pubs and plugs the uh the british plugs electrical why do you miss those i don't know too much about the differences there yeah well obviously the british plugs are famous for being ugly and enormous but um for someone who's passionate about design they're they're very well designed they're kind of beautifully so uh numerous like safety and convenience features built in let's see if i can remember them all it's been a while since i've done this uh this tirade uh but for one they stay in the socket so you can hang them from the ceiling and they have like they were deliberately designed to have like a lot of tension around the the plug parts would equal Yeah, they're out right? Yeah. Yeah so that you could yeah like hang things from them
pubs and plugs the uh the british plugs electrical why do you miss those i don't know too much about the differences there yeah well obviously the british plugs are famous for being ugly and enormous but um for someone who's passionate about design they're they're very well designed they're kind of beautifully so uh numerous like safety and convenience features built in let's see if i can remember them all it's been a while since i've done this uh this tirade uh but for one they stay in the socket so you can hang them from the ceiling and they have like they were deliberately designed to have like a lot of tension around the the plug parts would equal Yeah, they're out right? Yeah. Yeah so that you could yeah like hang things from them|||酒吧和插头，呃，英国的电气插头。你为什么会想念这些？我对那里的差异了解不多。嗯，很显然，英国插头以丑陋和巨大而闻名，但是，对于一个对设计充满热情的人来说，它们设计得非常好。它们在某种程度上非常精美，内置了许多安全和便利功能。让我想想能不能把它们全记住，我已经很久没有发表过这种长篇大论了。但首先，它们能牢牢卡在插座里，所以你可以把它们从天花板上垂下来挂着。它们被刻意设计成在插头部分周围有很大的张力，能够平衡……是的，它们拔不出来，对吧？对。所以你可以把东西挂在上面。
interesting Mandatory earthing so it's like safety feature and every every single socket has to have an external switch so you can turn it off at all every plug must have a fuse in it so it's fused safety wise as well and then the earth prong prong that's the word is slightly longer than the other two so it goes in first another safety feature so it's always grounded and the electrical the two that are actually live the socket in the wall has covers over those so that you can't like stick a finger or a fork in them and the covers only get removed when the earth pin goes in that's why it's slightly longer so it makes a mechanism that then reveals the live connection so there's no point where there's a hole that you can stick something in while you're using the plug unless you like you know force it open somehow that's probably all
interesting Mandatory earthing so it's like safety feature and every every single socket has to have an external switch so you can turn it off at all every plug must have a fuse in it so it's fused safety wise as well and then the earth prong prong that's the word is slightly longer than the other two so it goes in first another safety feature so it's always grounded and the electrical the two that are actually live the socket in the wall has covers over those so that you can't like stick a finger or a fork in them and the covers only get removed when the earth pin goes in that's why it's slightly longer so it makes a mechanism that then reveals the live connection so there's no point where there's a hole that you can stick something in while you're using the plug unless you like you know force it open somehow that's probably all|||真有意思。强制接地，所以这是一个安全特性。而且每一个插座都必须配备一个外部开关，这样你就能随时把它关掉。每个插头里必须有一个保险丝，所以在安全方面也是带保险丝的。然后是接地插脚——插脚，就是这个词——比另外两个稍微长一点，所以它会先生效，这也是另一个安全特性，这样就能确保始终处于接地状态。至于那两个真正带电的电极，墙上的插座有保护盖把它们盖住，这样你就不会把手指或叉子插进去。只有当接地销插入时，保护盖才会打开，这就是为什么它稍微长一点。这就构成了一种机制，只有在这时才会暴露出带电连接。所以在你使用插头的时候，根本没有哪个孔是你可以随便把东西插进去的，除非你……你知道的，用某种方式强行撬开它。这大概就是全部了
i can remember but you know i've always been like passionate about like these little bits of design that not everybody notices that are just like hidden there and so like i thought that was a bunch of neat things that someone spent the time to do a better job than American plugs, which are terrible. Yeah, I mean, what happened to me there is this house is a few decades old. And when we moved into it, I had the ring door chime plugged in in one of the outlets. And I came back a few days later and it was on the floor. It had just fallen out of the outlet. And so then I went through and had to replace a bunch of the outlet um things that are wired into the wall and sure enough yeah
i can remember but you know i've always been like passionate about like these little bits of design that not everybody notices that are just like hidden there and so like i thought that was a bunch of neat things that someone spent the time to do a better job than American plugs, which are terrible. Yeah, I mean, what happened to me there is this house is a few decades old. And when we moved into it, I had the ring door chime plugged in in one of the outlets. And I came back a few days later and it was on the floor. It had just fallen out of the outlet. And so then I went through and had to replace a bunch of the outlet um things that are wired into the wall and sure enough yeah|||我能记住的了。但你知道，我一直对这些并非所有人都能注意到、只是静静隐藏在那里的微小设计细节充满热情。所以我觉得这有很多巧妙之处，有人花时间把它们做得很完美，比美国插头好得多，美国插头太糟糕了。对，我的意思是，我在那儿经历过这样的事：这栋房子有几十年的历史了。当我们搬进来的时候，我把 Ring 门铃的蜂鸣器插在一个电源插座上。几天后我回来，它竟然掉在地上了。它就那样从插座里滑落了出来。于是我不得不去更换了一堆安装在墙里的电源插座……而且果然，是的
i wasn't that careful and i gave myself a shock so i got the it wasn't the 220 but i got the what is it 115 volt going through me for a moment which did not feel good you know that's certainly possible with the american ones but you know brit know, British voltage is 240, so that will kill you. Oh, 240, okay. Yeah. So it's part of the reason that there's all that extra safety in there. And, like, they are enormous. So, like, if you have, you know, typical desks set up for a computer,
i wasn't that careful and i gave myself a shock so i got the it wasn't the 220 but i got the what is it 115 volt going through me for a moment which did not feel good you know that's certainly possible with the american ones but you know brit know, British voltage is 240, so that will kill you. Oh, 240, okay. Yeah. So it's part of the reason that there's all that extra safety in there. And, like, they are enormous. So, like, if you have, you know, typical desks set up for a computer,|||我当时不够小心，结果电了自己一下。所以我——虽然不是 220 伏，但我体验了一下 115 伏的电流瞬间通过身体的感觉，那滋味真不好受。你知道，用美国的插头确实可能遇到这种情况，但英国的电压是 240 伏，那可是会要人命的。哦，240 伏，好吧。对。所以这也是那里会有那么多额外安全设计的部分原因。而且它们太巨大了。所以，如果你有一个典型的电脑桌设置的话，
the whole length of the desk will be, like, sockets behind it because you need that much space. So not everything is great that makes sense so you were uh you were commuting an hour away into london was it by mass transit or you were driving it yeah yeah like one thing that is nice about europe was that you could get everywhere by train or bus etc uh so i'd cycle to the to the train station get on the train which was usually on time this isn't german levels of promptness in britain but it wasn't too bad i think the british could system a hard time when it's relatively good 40 minutes on the train that would drop me at london
the whole length of the desk will be, like, sockets behind it because you need that much space. So not everything is great that makes sense so you were uh you were commuting an hour away into london was it by mass transit or you were driving it yeah yeah like one thing that is nice about europe was that you could get everywhere by train or bus etc uh so i'd cycle to the to the train station get on the train which was usually on time this isn't german levels of promptness in britain but it wasn't too bad i think the british could system a hard time when it's relatively good 40 minutes on the train that would drop me at london|||桌子后面的整排都会是插座，因为你需要那么大的空间。所以也不是每样东西都完美。这倒说得通。所以你以前是通勤一小时去伦敦上班，是坐公共交通还是自己开车？对，对。欧洲挺好的一点就是，你可以坐火车或公交车去任何地方。所以我骑自行车去火车站，然后坐火车，通常都很准时。虽然达不到德国那种严苛的准时程度，但在英国也算相当不错了。我觉得英国的铁路系统虽然常被诟病，但其实还算相对靠谱。坐 40 分钟的火车，把我送到伦敦的
euston so i'd get on the escalator go down onto the subway and then ride about five, six stops to Old Street, Shoreditch, which is famous in London for being full of startups. I think it probably still is that. And that's where Lost Femme was. So, yeah, that was the office trip. Interesting. And so that I always, you know, I felt like mass transit is better than sitting in a car for an hour. But I did feel like I'm a pretty tall person. So I was always kind of cramped. So I was kind of hunched over my laptop, you know, and every time the bus runs over a speed bump or something, the seat, you know, kind of partially closes my laptop and I have to open it again. It's, yeah, it's much nicer to kind of roll out of bed into the office. It's way better. Yeah, well, I did that for a bit while I worked at LastFam because I commuted for a year and then decided it was enough and I was going to move to London.
euston so i'd get on the escalator go down onto the subway and then ride about five, six stops to Old Street, Shoreditch, which is famous in London for being full of startups. I think it probably still is that. And that's where Lost Femme was. So, yeah, that was the office trip. Interesting. And so that I always, you know, I felt like mass transit is better than sitting in a car for an hour. But I did feel like I'm a pretty tall person. So I was always kind of cramped. So I was kind of hunched over my laptop, you know, and every time the bus runs over a speed bump or something, the seat, you know, kind of partially closes my laptop and I have to open it again. It's, yeah, it's much nicer to kind of roll out of bed into the office. It's way better. Yeah, well, I did that for a bit while I worked at LastFam because I commuted for a year and then decided it was enough and I was going to move to London.|||尤斯顿（Euston）站。然后我坐自动扶梯下到地铁站，再坐五六站到老街（Old Street）的肖尔迪奇（Shoreditch），这里在伦敦以充满初创公司而闻名。我想现在可能依然如此。Lost Femme 就开在那儿。所以，这就是去办公室的路线。很有意思。因此我一直觉得，坐公共交通比在车里坐一个小时要好。不过我确实觉得我个子挺高，所以总觉得空间有点局促。我总是驼着背对着笔记本电脑，你知道的，每当公交车压过减速带之类的东西时，座位就会把我的笔记本电脑撞得合上一点，我又得把它打开。所以，从床上滚下来直接进办公室的感觉要美好得多，好太多了。对，我在 LastFam 工作期间也这么干过一段时间，我通勤了一年，然后觉得受够了，决定搬到伦敦去。
But I didn't want to be in the situation of rushing to find a flat. So I took a tent and lived on the roof of the office for about three months yeah there was a an abandoned lift shaft and at the top it was sealed and i stuck my tent in there um i never i didn't tell my boss and they found out and weren't very happy about it but it wasn't their building so they went too fast so so yeah you went three months how did a custodian not see that there was a tent there um i don't know like british landlords are very thorough i guess wow that is wild but i did literally like get out of bed stumble downstairs after after a few weeks i uh you know wore my pajamas downstairs brushed my teeth got some coffee
But I didn't want to be in the situation of rushing to find a flat. So I took a tent and lived on the roof of the office for about three months yeah there was a an abandoned lift shaft and at the top it was sealed and i stuck my tent in there um i never i didn't tell my boss and they found out and weren't very happy about it but it wasn't their building so they went too fast so so yeah you went three months how did a custodian not see that there was a tent there um i don't know like british landlords are very thorough i guess wow that is wild but i did literally like get out of bed stumble downstairs after after a few weeks i uh you know wore my pajamas downstairs brushed my teeth got some coffee|||但我又不想陷入急着找公寓的窘境。于是我带了个帐篷，在办公室屋顶住了大约三个月。对，那里有一个废弃的电梯井，顶部是密封的，我把帐篷搭在了里面。我从来没告诉过我老板，后来他们发现了，对此非常不高兴，但这又不是他们的建筑，所以他们也没法……所以，你竟然住了三个月？管理员怎么会没看见那里有个帐篷？嗯，我不知道，可能英国的房东做事非常严谨吧。哇，这也太疯狂了。但我确实是那种起床后跌跌撞撞地下楼——过了一阵子之后，我穿着睡衣下楼，刷牙，喝咖啡
and everyone was just used to it it was a real startup way of uh existence for sure that's awesome yeah the uh they don't have that giant hr department to kind of crack the whip on that there was an issue uh at there was an issue at google where people were sleeping in the conference rooms that was a really big deal because I think it's also, you know, the rent is probably similar to London. The rent is so expensive that you could save you an entire year's salary if you just found a way to sleep at the office. Yeah, well, I can understand why they would be doing it for that reason. Well, London's pricey, but it's not San Francisco. People are more used to sharing
and everyone was just used to it it was a real startup way of uh existence for sure that's awesome yeah the uh they don't have that giant hr department to kind of crack the whip on that there was an issue at google where people were sleeping in the conference rooms that was a really big deal because I think it's also, you know, the rent is probably similar to London. The rent is so expensive that you could save you an entire year's salary if you just found a way to sleep at the office. Yeah, well, I can understand why they would be doing it for that reason. Well, London's pricey, but it's not San Francisco. People are more used to sharing|||大家也都习以为常了。这绝对是一种真正的初创公司式的生存方式。太棒了。对，呃，他们没有那种挥舞着皮鞭的庞大 HR 部门来管这事。谷歌曾出过一件事，有人睡在会议室里，那可闹得挺大的，因为我觉得这也是因为，你知道的，那里的房租可能跟伦敦差不多。房租贵得离谱，如果你能想办法睡在办公室里，甚至能省下一整年的薪水。是的，我能理解他们为什么会出于这个原因这么做。好吧，伦敦物价虽高，但毕竟不是旧金山。人们更习惯于合租
flats, as they call it. Cool. So it sounds like TXYZ is fully remote, or at least embraces remote since the beginning. Yes, we already have. We just hired someone from India. It's a bit America-centric at the moment for me. One of the things I wanted to do with this company is because it's commercial open source. And for me, open source is about, it's a global thing. It's not a Western thing. It's not an American thing. It's not a European thing.
flats, as they call it. Cool. So it sounds like TXYZ is fully remote, or at least embraces remote since the beginning. Yes, we already have. We just hired someone from India. It's a bit America-centric at the moment for me. One of the things I wanted to do with this company is because it's commercial open source. And for me, open source is about, it's a global thing. It's not a Western thing. It's not an American thing. It's not a European thing.|||公寓，他们是这么叫的。太酷了。听起来 TXYZ 是完全远程办公，或者至少从一开始就拥抱远程办公。是的，我们已经是了。我们刚从印度招了一个人。目前对我来说，公司还是有点以美国为中心。我创立这家公司时想做的事情之一，是因为它是商业开源项目。对我而言，开源是一件全球化的事情。它不是西方的事，不是美国的事，也不是欧洲的事。
I said from the start, I want someone in every time zone. So it was always going to be like this split company. And as I say, for me, I started in open source and I was used to waking up and people had been working overnight. And I'd have to figure out how to slot that work back in with what I was doing. And then make sure that we were planning from, you know, not being able to talk to each other in person, even over the phone. So, you know, it was natural for me to want this company to be that way and to know how to manage that from the start.
I said from the start, I want someone in every time zone. So it was always going to be like this split company. And as I say, for me, I started in open source and I was used to waking up and people had been working overnight. And I'd have to figure out how to slot that work back in with what I was doing. And then make sure that we were planning from, you know, not being able to talk to each other in person, even over the phone. So, (you know,) it was natural for me to want this company to be that way and to know how to manage that from the start.|||我从一开始就说过，我希望每个时区都有我们的人。所以它注定会是一家分散在各地的公司。正如我所说，对我来说，我从开源起家，我已经习惯了醒来时发现别人已经通宵工作过了。我必须想方设法把那些工作成果和我正在做的事情结合起来。然后确保我们在无法面对面交流（甚至无法通过电话交流）的情况下进行规划。所以，对我来说，让这家公司成为这样，并且从一开始就知道如何管理这种模式，是非常自然的事情。
And so we're gradually getting to that point. And yeah, we do have an office in Puerto Rico, which is where we're founded. We call it the Tea House. And it's a fun place that is more of a house than an office, several floors for working and several floors for sleeping. So that when we do, we'll meet up and we'll be meeting up next month. There's places for people to stay. And so we say hi for a few days.
And so we're gradually getting to that point. And yeah, we do have an office in Puerto Rico, which is where we're founded. We call it the Tea House. And it's a fun place that is more of a house than an office, several floors for working and several floors for sleeping. So that when we do, we'll meet up and we'll be meeting up next month. There's places for people to stay. And so we say hi for a few days.|||我们正在逐渐实现这个目标。是的，我们在波多黎各确实有一个办公室，那是我们创立公司的地方。我们叫它“茶室”（Tea House）。这是一个有趣的地方，与其说是办公室，不如说更像是一栋房子，有几层用来工作，有几层用来睡觉。这样当我们要聚会时——我们下个月就要聚会了——大家就有地方住。我们可以聚在一起打几天招呼。
And you can do that more with the fact that we're a funded company than I ever could be ever could when we were doing open source. I remember when I was working on apps for Linux and things like that back in 2005 2005 or so and we would meet up like once a year all of us who were working on uh whatever it was and you know that was paid for generously by donations from the community but not everyone could always make it because you know people from all over the world but it was good just to say hi see what people are like have a few drinks and dinner with people
And you can do that more with the fact that we're a funded company than I ever could be ever could when we were doing open source. I remember when I was working on apps for Linux and things like that back in 2005 2005 or so and we would meet up like once a year all of us who were working on uh whatever it was and you know that was paid for generously by donations from the community but not everyone could always make it because you know people from all over the world but it was good just to say hi see what people are like have a few drinks and dinner with people|||而且相比当年我们做开源的时候，现在作为一家获得融资的公司，我们更有能力做到这一点。我记得在 2005 年左右，当我为 Linux 开发应用程序时，所有从事某种开发工作的人大约一年会聚会一次。你知道，那是靠社区的慷慨捐赠资助的，但并不是每个人都能每次都来，因为大家来自世界各地。不过能聚在一起打个招呼、看看大家是什么样的人、和大家一起喝几杯、吃顿晚饭，感觉真的很棒。
play some games doing doing things that you know not the standard things and i think remote companies need to recognize the fact that you do have to meet up once in a while and you need to do things that aren't just work because otherwise you have people that are just building relationships and all it ever is is work related like at t we have every month we play a game of werewolf over zoom the point of that is to just like make sure that people you know shout at each other a bit essentially in like in a good spirited way get some uh get some emotional contact like just get to know each other as friends, not just colleagues. Yeah, that makes sense. Do you try to meet in person like once a quarter, once a year, once a month?
play some games doing doing things that you know not the standard things and i think remote companies need to recognize the fact that you do have to meet up once in a while and you need to do things that aren't just work because otherwise you have people that are just building relationships and all it ever is is work related like at t we have every month we play a game of werewolf over zoom the point of that is to just like make sure that people you know shout at each other a bit essentially in like in a good spirited way get some uh get some emotional contact like just get to know each other as friends, not just colleagues. Yeah, that makes sense. Do you try to meet in person like once a quarter, once a year, once a month?|||玩玩游戏，做一些……你知道的，不是标准工作内容的事情。我认为远程公司必须认识到这样一件事：你们确实需要偶尔聚一聚，而且需要做一些不仅仅是工作的事情，否则大家建立起来的关系就完全只和工作相关。比如在 TXYZ，我们每个月都会通过 Zoom 玩一局狼人杀。这样做的目的就是确保大家能……你知道的，互相大喊大叫一番，本质上是以一种充满活力、精神饱满的方式，建立一些情感联系，不仅仅把对方当同事，而是作为朋友去了解彼此。是的，这很有道理。你们会尝试每季度、每年还是每月进行一次线下聚会？
What's the cadence there and how does that affect things? Yeah, we're doing once a quarter. Like the company was founded last December, but we only finished securing the first round in April. And then we've been staffing up since then. So we're still quite small and only recently exceeded like 12 to 13 people. We don't really have a pattern to it yet. But the plan is every quarter, indeed.
What's the cadence there and how does that affect things? Yeah, we're doing once a quarter. Like the company was founded last December, but we only finished securing the first round in April. And then we've been staffing up since then. So we're still quite small and only recently exceeded like 12 to 13 people. We don't really have a pattern to it yet. But the plan is every quarter, indeed.|||你们的频率是怎样的？这对公司有什么影响？对，我们目前是一季度一次。公司是去年 12 月创立的，但我们在 4 月才完成首轮融资。从那以后我们一直在招兵买马。所以我们规模还挺小的，直到最近人数才刚超过 12、13 人的样子。我们目前还没有形成固定的模式。但计划确实是每个季度聚一次。
And so far, that's working. Cool. That makes sense. So I want to kind of work us up to Homebrew, which I'm sure anybody out there who uses Mac is familiar with. But kind of work us through, you know, how did you get into open source? And, you know, kind of what was the journey that led you to kind of put the pen down and say, I'm going to build Homebrew? You know, what was that whole progression like? So programming has always been a hobby for me. My dad sat me down in front of a BBC micro,
And so far, that's working. Cool. That makes sense. So I want to kind of work us up to Homebrew, which I'm sure anybody out there who uses Mac is familiar with. But kind of work us through, you0** know, how did you get into open source? And, (you know,) kind of what was the journey that led you to kind of put the pen down and say, I'm going to build Homebrew? You0** know, what was that whole progression like? So programming has always been a hobby for me. My dad sat me down in front of a BBC micro,|||目前看来效果还不错。太好了，这说得通。那么我想把话题逐渐引向 Homebrew，我相信任何使用 Mac 的人对它都很熟悉。能跟我们讲讲你是怎么接触开源的吗？以及，是什么样的心路历程促使你停下手头的事情，决定自己开发 Homebrew？整个过程是怎样的？编程对一直我来说都是一种爱好。我爸爸让我坐在一台 BBC Micro 计算机前，
which was this computer that everyone in Britain had in the 90s. I still don't know if the BBC just slapped their logo on it or they actually had an active hand in making it the British Broadcasting Corporation. But it was called the BBC Micro. And my dad sat me down in front of it and taught me a bit of programming one day. And I really got something out of it.
which was this computer that everyone in Britain had in the 90s. I still don't know if the BBC just slapped their logo on it or they actually had an active hand in making it the British Broadcasting Corporation. But it was called the BBC Micro. And my dad sat me down in front of it and taught me a bit of programming one day. And I really got something out of it.|||那是 90 年代英国人手一台的电脑。我至今不知道英国广播公司（BBC）是只是把他们的标志贴在上面，还是真的积极参与了它的制造。但它确实叫 BBC Micro。有一天，我爸爸让我坐在它前面，教了我一点编程。我真的从中收获了很多。
So I kept coming back to it as a hobby. So was your dad an engineer or was he a hobbyist or how did that work? Yeah, he was a, he was just a hobbyist as well. He dabbled in many different things over his life, but he was super passionate about electronics. And then when personal computing became a thing, he was like first in line to pick one up. He was always very interested in it. But yeah, he never did it as a career or anything. And his programming ability was pretty amateur, but it was enough to get me the spark so that I could understand how to progress.
So I kept coming back to it as a hobby. So was your dad an engineer or was he a hobbyist or how did that work? Yeah, he was a, he was just a hobbyist as well. He dabbled in many different things over his life, but he was super passionate about electronics. And then when personal computing became a thing, he was like first in line to pick one up. He was always very interested in it. But yeah, he never did it as a career or anything. And his programming ability was pretty amateur, but it was enough to get me the spark so that I could understand how to progress.|||所以它一直作为我的爱好，让我不断回味。那你爸爸是一名工程师，还是个爱好者，还是怎么回事？对，他只是个爱好者。他一生涉猎过许多不同的领域，但他对电子学有着极大的热情。后来，当个人电脑兴起时，他绝对是第一批买一台回家的人。他一直对它非常感兴趣。但对，他从来没有把这当作职业什么的。他的编程能力相当业余，但足以点燃我的火花，让我懂得如何继续前进。
Well, part of the reason it was easy with the BBC Micro is because it booted straight to a prompt that was BBC Basic, so a basic programming language. It wasn't a shell like Bash. It was a shell which was programming. And so I could straightaway get into writing little programs. And so obviously I made games, and I made games for years. Little toys.
Well, part of the reason it was easy with the BBC Micro is because it booted straight to a prompt that was BBC Basic, so a basic programming language. It wasn't a shell like Bash. It was a shell which was programming. And so I could straightaway get into writing little programs. And so obviously I made games, and I made games for years. Little toys.|||嗯，BBC Micro 容易上手的部分原因在于，它开机后会直接启动到一个提示符，即 BBC Basic，也就是一门基础的编程语言。它不是像 Bash 那样的外壳程序，而是一个本身就是编程环境的外壳。所以我可以立刻开始编写小程序。很显然，我做了游戏，而且做了好几年的游戏，都是些小玩具。
I remember one time I started making something that I called Windows 4 because at the called Windows 4. Because at the time Windows 3.1 was the thing. I was just experimenting, essentially. And at school, during my lunch break, there was a little clique of us geeks who'd go in and just program stuff. And we competed to see who could make the first scrolling adventure game and things like that and like put music on it um so it's always something that i really enjoyed but of course the school didn't teach it wasn't it wasn't a lesson this was the 90s so it wasn't something that was typically taught and i never really considered it as a career so i ended up going to i got a master's in chemistry and um the third year of my degree
I remember one time I started making something that I called Windows 4 because at the called Windows 4. Because at the time Windows 3.1 was the thing. I was just experimenting, essentially. And at school, during my lunch break, there was a little clique of us geeks who'd go in and just program stuff. And we competed to see who could make the first scrolling adventure game and things like that and like put music on it um so it's always something that i really enjoyed but of course the school didn't teach it wasn't it wasn't a lesson this was the 90s so it wasn't something that was typically taught and i never really considered it as a career so i ended up going to i got a master's in chemistry and um the third year of my degree|||我记得有一次，我开始制作一个我称之为“Windows 4”的东西，因为当时 Windows 3.1 正大行其道。我本质上只是在做实验。在学校里，午休时，我们几个极客会聚在一起编写程序。我们比赛看谁能做出第一个滚动冒险游戏之类的东西，还在上面配上音乐。所以这总是我非常喜欢的事情。但当然，学校并没有教这个，这不是一门课程——那是 90 年代，这不是通常会教的内容，而且我从来没把它当成一种职业来考虑。所以我最后去读了化学硕士学位。在我读学位的第三年，
i went off to work in industry uh for a year and for the first month i really enjoyed it and i was like messing around with the the big machines and having some fun now like just sorry when i think of chemists i have this stereotype of a person in a lab coat with a beaker and a pipette you know mixing like fluids like is that is that what you did or like kind of like can you educate us on like what the chemists do well you're not far off honestly the lab coat i worked in a physical chemistry lab so there's three kinds of chemistry organic inorganic and physical it's like strange how the first two are just complements of each other and physical chemistry so it had more math or
i went off to work in industry uh for a year and for the first month i really enjoyed it and i was like messing around with the the big machines and having some fun now like just sorry when i think of chemists i have this stereotype of a person in a lab coat with a beaker and a pipette you know mixing like fluids like is that is that what you did or like kind of like can you educate us on like what the chemists do well you're not far off honestly the lab coat i worked in a physical chemistry lab so there's three kinds of chemistry organic inorganic and physical it's like strange how the first two are just complements of each other and physical chemistry so it had more math or|||我出去在工业界工作了一年。第一个月我真的很喜欢，我摆弄着那些大机器，觉得挺好玩的。现在，就像——抱歉，一想到化学家，我的脑海里就会浮现出一个刻板印象：穿着白大褂的人，拿着烧杯和移液管，你知道的，在混合各种液体。你是干这个的吗？能给我们科普一下化学家到底是做什么的吗？嗯，说实话，你猜得八九不离十。白大褂确实穿。我在一个物理化学实验室工作——化学分为三种：有机化学、无机化学和物理化学。奇怪的是，前两者的关系就像是互补的，而物理化学则包含更多的数学或
physics in it than most chemistry and this is the raw one like as physicists will tell you like physics is the real science and then everything else is an applied version of physics and yeah you know physical chemistry was really them saying yeah it's true chemistry is just at the end of the day like raw physics going on down there like electrons are just strangely all anywhere i won't teach chemistry on this podcast but so i was doing physical chemistry which mostly meant like i was measuring physical properties of different things that other people in other labs had made so i was measuring the surface tension of surfactants because i worked at kodak there was a big kodak factory in london at the time i heard recently it's closed down obviously kodak so well over the last 20 years right this was uh 2002 i think uh so i was measuring surface tension and for a while i i used
physics in it than most chemistry and this is the raw one like as physicists will tell you like physics is the real science and then everything else is an applied version of physics and yeah you know physical chemistry was really them saying yeah it's true chemistry is just at the end of the day like raw physics going on down there like electrons are just strangely all anywhere i won't teach chemistry on this podcast but so i was doing physical chemistry which mostly meant like i was measuring physical properties of different things that other people in other labs had made so i was measuring the surface tension of surfactants because i worked at kodak there was a big kodak factory in london at the time i heard recently it's closed down obviously kodak so well over the last 20 years right this was uh 2002 i think uh so i was measuring surface tension and for a while i i used|||物理知识，比大多数化学分支都多。这是最底层的科学，就像物理学家会告诉你的那样：物理学才是真正的科学，其他一切都是物理学的应用版本。是的，你知道，物理化学实际上就是他们在说：没错，归根结底，化学不过是底层正在发生的原汁原味的物理现象罢了，电子只是在各种地方奇怪地游荡。我可不在这个播客里教化学。总之，我当时在做物理化学，这主要意味着我要测量其他人、在其他实验室里制造的不同物质的物理性质。我在测量表面活性剂的表面积，因为我当时在柯达工作。那时候伦敦有一家大型柯达工厂，我最近听说它已经关门了。显然，柯达在过去的 20 里经历了巨大的变化，对吧？那是 2002 年左右吧。所以我当时在测量表面活性剂的表面积。有一段时间，我使用
this like large machine that i had to calibrate and get the hang of it and i enjoyed mastering the machine um but then i went home for christmas and while i was there i realized that i hated it the work was boring and i fell into this huge depression over the next six months where I realized that I hadn't picked the right thing for my career. And I didn't know what to do with myself. So I started programming again, because it seemed like it was fun. I still Linux. And I found open source. Essentially, I discovered open source as just a route trying to find something else to do with myself. Now, how did you do that? So this is the 90s, right? So you weren't on America Online. You weren't on America Online because you're in the UK.
this like large machine that i had to calibrate and get the hang of it and i enjoyed mastering the machine but then i went home for christmas and while i was there i realized that i hated it the work was boring and i fell into this huge depression over the next six months where I realized that I hadn't picked the right thing for my career. And I didn't know what to do with myself. So I started programming again, because it seemed like it was fun. I still Linux. And I found open source. Essentially, I discovered open source as just a route trying to find something else to do with myself. Now, how did you do that? So this is the 90s, right? So you weren't on America Online. You weren't on America Online because you're in the UK.|||一台大型机器，我必须对它进行校准并掌握它的使用方法。我挺喜欢征服这台机器的感觉。但后来我回家过圣诞节，在那里的时候，我突然意识到我讨厌这份工作。工作很无聊，在接下来的六个月里，我陷入了巨大的抑郁之中，我意识到自己选错了职业。我不知道自己该做什么。于是我重新开始编程，因为这看起来很有趣。我依然喜欢 Linux。然后我发现了开源。本质上，我发现开源只是我为了寻找人生其他出路而走上的一条途径。那么，你是怎么做到的？这是 90 年代，对吧？所以你当时没用美国在线（AOL）。你没有用美国在线，因为你在英国。
But you're on some... What was the discovery process like back then? Yeah, well, different certainly. So it was 2002, so not quite as nascent. We had broadband internet, so you had a noise-on connection where you didn't have to dial up. And the web was coming along. The web was certainly coming along before Stack Overflow
But you're on some... What was the discovery process like back then? Yeah, well, different certainly. So it was 2002, so not quite as nascent. We had broadband internet, so you had a noise-on connection where you didn't have to dial up. And the web was coming along. The web was certainly coming along before Stack Overflow|||但你用了一些……当时的探索过程是怎样的？是的，当然很不一样。那是 2002 年，所以不像早期那么稚嫩了。我们有了宽带互联网，也就是那种不用拨号的常在线连接。而且网络正在兴起。在 Stack Overflow 出现之前，网络就已经在蓬勃发展了
and things like that, obviously. So, yeah, like, I heard of Linux because of some of the places on the internet I'd been in the late 90s. I used to hang out on this music player forum for this music player called Sonic. There was like two major, because MP3s obviously changed how music was and how it was consumed. And that was a relatively exciting period in the internet. So there was like Winamp was the big one. Right, right.
and things like that, obviously. So, yeah, like, I heard of Linux because of some of the places on the internet I'd been in the late 90s. I used to hang out on this music player forum for this music player called Sonic. There was like two major, because MP3s obviously changed how music was and how it was consumed. And that was a relatively exciting period in the internet. So there was like Winamp was the big one. Right, right.|||和诸如此类的东西出现之前，显然是这样的。所以，是的，我听说 Linux 是因为我在 90 年代末去过互联网上的一些地方。我经常泡在一个名为 Sonic 的音乐播放器的论坛上。当时有两个主流的……因为 MP3 显然改变了音乐的形态以及音乐被消费的方式。那是互联网上一个相对令人兴奋的时期。当时 Winamp 是最大的那个。对，对。
And it still exists. I don't know if anyone still uses it. Like AOL bought it. Oh, that's right. And then there was that one called Sonic, which was a much smaller one, but it was kind of like the number two. And I liked it because it had really interesting skins. Like the music could like interact with the skin itself.
And it still exists. I don't know if anyone still uses it. Like AOL bought it. Oh, that's right. And then there was that one called Sonic, which was a much smaller one, but it was kind of like the number two. And I liked it because it had really interesting skins. Like the music could like interact with the skin itself.|||它现在还存在。我不知道是否还有人在用它。比如 AOL 收购了它。哦，对。然后还有那个叫 Sonic 的播放器，它要小得多，但它有点像老二。我喜欢它是因为它有非常有趣的皮肤。比如音乐可以和皮肤本身产生互动。
I don't know, like, you know, downloading mp3s it was illegal and fun but there was a big forum of people who talked and i got to know a lot of these people on there for some reason or another and like a few of them used linux so i heard of linux by this you know little community of people that appealed to me so when I was trying to figure out what to do with myself, I was like, I should install Linux. So I... Where did I get... Because you had to get a CD back then basically.
I don't know, like, you know, downloading mp3s it was illegal and fun but there was a big forum of people who talked and i got to know a lot of these people on there for some reason or another and like a few of them used linux so i heard of linux by this you, (little) community of people that appealed to me so when I was trying to figure out what to do with myself, I was like, I should install Linux. So I... Where did I get... Because you had to get a CD back then basically.|||我不知道，就像，你知道的，下载 MP3 是非法的，但很有趣。那里有一个很大的论坛，大家在上面聊天，由于种种原因，我在上面认识了很多人。其中有几个人用 Linux，所以我通过这个吸引我的小社区听说了 Linux。所以当我试图弄清楚自己该做什么时，我想：“我应该安装 Linux。”于是我……我从哪儿弄到……因为那时候你基本上必须得有一张光盘。
Because downloading... Yeah, you could download it. It would take forever. Exactly, yeah. Downloading half a gigabyte of 600 megish would be a couple of days at that point. So you would, you know,
Because downloading... Yeah, you could download it. It would take forever. Exactly, yeah. Downloading half a gigabyte of 600 megish would be a couple of days at that point. So you would, you know,|||因为下载……对，你可以下载。那得花上永恒的时间。没错，对。在当时，下载半个吉字节（约 600 多兆）的东西得花上好几天。所以你会……你知道的，
like, I don't know if Ubuntu exists at this point, but equivalents of Ubuntu would allow you to, for very cheap, mail off for a CD and they'd mail you back. Oh, I didn't know that. I remember using this program called FXP,
like, I don't know if Ubuntu exists at this point, but equivalents of Ubuntu would allow you to, for very cheap, mail off for a CD and they'd mail you back. Oh, I didn't know that. I remember using this program called FXP,|||我不知道此时 Ubuntu 是否已经存在，但类似 Ubuntu 的发行版会允许你花很少的钱写信索取一张光盘，然后他们会把光盘寄给你。哦，我不知道这个。我记得我曾用过一个叫 FXP 的程序，
which would basically allow you to resume FTP, which I think you could do anyways. I don't really know what that program even added, any value it added, but I remember I would turn that on and then sure enough, like my parents would pick up the phone and kill the internet, you know, ruin it, and have to resume.
which would basically allow you to resume FTP, which I think you could do anyways. I don't really know what that program even added, any value it added, but I remember I would turn that on and then sure enough, like my parents would pick up the phone and kill the internet, you know, ruin it, and have to resume.|||它基本上允许你恢复断点续传的 FTP 下载——虽然我觉得你本来就能做到这一点。我其实不知道那个程序究竟增加了什么价值，但我记得我打开它，然后果不其然，我父母一拿起电话就把网络给掐断了——你知道的，把下载毁了——然后我又得恢复下载。
Or I think eventually we also got cable or DSL or whatever it was. And yeah, it went from taking three days to one day and you'd sit there and wait. Yeah, indeed. There was a lot of tools that existed because of the limitations on what you could do back then. Like the first open source app I made was a file usage explorer because I had a three gigabyte hard disk. And so it was very important to me that I didn't have to delete any more music than I wanted to.
Or I think eventually we also got cable or DSL or whatever it was. And yeah, it went from taking three days to one day and you'd sit there and wait. Yeah, indeed. There was a lot of tools that existed because of the limitations on what you could do back then. Like the first open source app I made was a file usage explorer because I had a three gigabyte hard disk. And so it was very important to me that I didn't have to delete any more music than I wanted to.|||或者我想我们后来也装了有线宽带、DSL 或是别的什么。然后，是的，下载时间从三天缩短到了一天，你就坐在那儿等着。确实如此。当时存在着很多工具，这都是由于当时的技术局限性造成的。比如我制作的第一个开源应用程序是一个磁盘空间使用率浏览器，因为我当时只有一个 3 GB 的硬盘。对我来说，最重要的是我不用删掉任何我不想删的音乐。
And that I could use my computer and figure out where all the disk storage was going and who was being a bad actor. And of course, nowadays, no one cares. Those tools don't exist. Just like your FTP program for resuming FTP, it probably still exists, but I doubt that many people use it or maintain it because
And that I could use my computer and figure out where all the disk storage was going and who was being a bad actor. And of course, nowadays, no one cares. Those tools don't exist. Just like your FTP program for resuming FTP, it probably still exists, but I doubt that many people use it or maintain it because|||而且我可以用我的电脑查出所有的磁盘空间都去哪儿了，到底是谁在“捣乱”。当然，现在没人关心这个了，那些工具也都不存在了。就像你那个用来做 FTP 断点续传的程序一样，它可能现在还存在，但我怀疑还有多少人在使用或维护它，因为
if a download fails nowadays, then you just try again and two minutes later, you've got the whole thing, even if it's huge. Or you're using a more sophisticated protocol like, for instance bit torrent which is uh really the way that these things should be transferred nowadays yeah so i set off for the cd and that's how i got into it and then you know it was addicting like learning how an operating system works until then i'd only use windows and i didn't have to know that much
if a download fails nowadays, then you just try again and two minutes later, you've got the whole thing, even if it's huge. Or you're using a more sophisticated protocol like, for instance bit torrent which is uh really the way that these things should be transferred nowadays yeah so i set off for the cd and that's how i got into it and then you0** know, it was addicting like learning how an operating system works until then i'd only use windows and i didn't have to know that much|||现在如果下载失败了，你只要重试一下，两分钟后整个文件就下好了，哪怕它非常巨大。或者你会使用更先进的协议，比如 BitTorrent，这才是如今传输这类东西的真正方式。是的，所以我申请了光盘，这就是我入坑的方式。然后，你知道的，这太让人上瘾了，比如学习操作系统是如何工作的。在此之前我只用过 Windows，我根本不需要了解那么多
about how it works because microsoft spent a lot of time making sure it works. Linux doesn't usually work even nowadays, let's face it. You have to be a bit more passionate, but it's there for you if you want to become passionate and learn how these things worked. I'm glad that I went that route. Honestly, it taught me a lot about how operating systems worked. And in many ways, it developed my passion for package managers because it's just such a key part of Linux.
about how it works because microsoft spent a lot of time making sure it works. Linux doesn't usually work even nowadays, let's face it. You have to be a bit more passionate, but it's there for you if you want to become passionate and learn how these things worked. I'm glad that I went that route. Honestly, it taught me a lot about how operating systems worked. And in many ways, it developed my passion for package managers because it's just such a key part of Linux.|||关于它内部工作原理的知识，因为微软花了很多时间来确保它能正常运行。说实话，Linux 哪怕到了今天，通常也不是拿来就能用的。你必须具备更多的工作热情，但如果你愿意充满热情并学习这些东西是如何工作的，它就在那里等着你。我很高兴我走了那条路。老实说，它教会了我很多关于操作系统工作原理的知识。在很多方面，它培养了我对包管理器的热爱，因为这实在是 Linux 中至关重要的一部分。
Yeah, I remember getting, I think, Mandrake was the first one that I looked into. And just the package manager blew my mind. Like, I mean, there was, I don't know, thousands and thousands of packages even back then. And I just remember being like, just completely amazed, like just shocked at what I could do. It's like, oh, here's a package that does fluid simulation. I don't know what that is, but it sounds freaking cool. Like I like, I like the ocean. And if I can make the ocean on the computer, it looks awesome.
Yeah, I remember getting, I think, Mandrake was the first one that I looked into. And just the package manager blew my mind. Like, I mean, there was, I don't know, thousands and thousands of packages even back then. And I just remember being like, just completely amazed, like just shocked at what I could do. It's like, oh, here's a package that does fluid simulation. I don't know what that is, but it sounds freaking cool. Like I like, I like the ocean. And if I can make the ocean on the computer, it looks awesome.|||是的，我记得我接触的第一个 Linux 发行版好像是 Mandrake。仅仅是它的包管理器就彻底震撼了我。我的意思是，哪怕在那个时候，也有成千上万个软件包。我只记得自己当时感到完全被惊艳到了，被我所能做到的事情震惊了。就好比，“哦，这里有一个做流体模拟的包。我不知道那是什么，但听起来酷毙了。”就像我喜欢大海，如果能在电脑上造出大海，那看起来一定棒极了。
And so, you know, then you go to the website and you see like the wave propagation and all these things, visualizations of it. I get you excited about that. And then you're just going down the list. Like here's graph libraries. There's all these things. Here's like a free version of paint, like a free version of Photoshop. That's like almost as good as Photoshoposhop like it was just mind-blowing and and that's something that
And so, (you know,) then you go to the website and you see like the wave propagation and all these things, visualizations of it. I get you excited about that. And then you're just going down the list. Like here's graph libraries. There's all these things. Here's like a free version of paint, like a free version of Photoshop. That's like almost as good as Photoshoposhop like it was just mind-blowing and and that's something that|||然后，你知道的，你访问那个网站，看到波的传播以及所有这些东西的视觉化呈现。这会让你感到兴奋。接着你就会顺着列表一直看下去。比如这里有图形库，有各种各样的东西。这里还有一个免费版的画图软件，类似于免费版的 Photoshop，几乎和 Photoshop 一样好用——这简直太让人大开眼界了，而且
you know as we get um kind of older and more like familiar with these things we try to take it for granted but like all of us went through that phase where we just kind of randomly scrolled through the package manager and saw just unbelievable amounts of human productivity and human effort. Yeah, I hadn't thought about that in a long time, but you're completely right. I forget how amazing it was that first time. I think I installed Mandrake at one point. I remember a 2E, they call them now, the terminal
you know as we get um kind of older and more like familiar with these things we try to take it for granted but like all of us went through that phase where we just kind of randomly scrolled through the package manager and saw just unbelievable amounts of human productivity and human effort. Yeah, I hadn't thought about that in a long time, but you're completely right. I forget how amazing it was that first time. I think I installed Mandrake at one point. I remember a 2E, they call them now, the terminal|||随着我们变老，对这些东西越来越熟悉，我们会认为这一切都是理所当然的。但我们所有人都经历过这样一个阶段：我们在包管理器里随意滚动浏览，看到了令人难以置信的大量人类生产力和人类心血。是的，我好久没想过这个了，但你完全说对了。我都忘了第一次看到时那种惊叹的感觉。我想我曾经安装过 Mandrake。我记得当时有一个叫什么来着……现在他们管这叫终端
user interfaces. Well, actually, it's not terminal. It stands for something else. I forget. Text, perhaps. Unexpected. And yeah, the browsing, this large collection. In fact, it's influenced a T we consider what we're building to be a
user interfaces. Well, actually, it's not terminal. It stands for something else. I forget. Text, perhaps. Unexpected. And yeah, the browsing, this large collection. In fact, it's influenced a T we consider what we're building to be a|||用户界面。嗯，其实不是终端（Terminal），它的缩写代表别的词，我忘了。也许是 Text（文本）。真没想到。是的，那种浏览庞大软件库的体验……事实上，这影响了我们在 TXYZ 的做法，我们认为我们正在构建的
kind of app store, for example. And these package managers, in many ways, like the original app stores the original way to like find and install like huge amounts of free open source software and it really was quite amazing seeing all the all the things that people were doing like that was inspiring for me for sure uh because you know i'm the kind of person that whenever I use something, I, I find something that I don't like about it. And then if I don't like it for long enough, I want to do something about it. And my co-founder says that if you want Max to do something, just make sure he's frustrated with it. And it's basically, basically true. So,
kind of app store, for example. And these package managers, in many ways, like the original app stores the original way to like find and install like huge amounts of free open source software and it really was quite amazing seeing all the all the things that people were doing like that was inspiring for me for sure uh because you know i'm the kind of person that whenever I use something, I, I find something that I don't like about it. And then if I don't like it for long enough, I want to do something about it. And my co-founder says that if you want Max to do something, just make sure he's frustrated with it. And it's basically, basically true. So,|||是一种应用商店。这些包管理器在许多方面就像最初的应用商店一样，是寻找和安装大量免费开源软件的最初途径。看到人们在做所有这些事情，真的非常神奇——这绝对给了我很多启发。因为你知道的，我是那种无论使用什么东西，总能挑出毛病的人。如果我对某个东西的不满累积得够久，我就会想做点什么去改变它。我的联合创始人曾说：“如果你想让 Max 去做一件事，只要确保他对此感到沮丧就行了。”这基本上、基本上是事实。所以，
you know, I love them, but also hated them. You know, some of the older ones. So what did you hate about them? Like, I remember trying out Debian and wanting to install some package that wasn't in their package registry. So people would provide like a deb you could download, a.deb. And like the first time,
you know, I love them, but also hated them. You know, some of the older ones. So what did you hate about them? Like, I remember trying out Debian and wanting to install some package that wasn't in their package registry. So people would provide like a deb you could download, a.deb. And like the first time,|||你知道的，我热爱它们，但也痛恨它们。我是指其中一些比较老旧的包管理器。那你讨厌它们的什么地方？比如，我记得我尝试过 Debian，当时我想安装一个不在他们软件包注册表里的包。人们会提供一个你可以下载的 .deb 文件。第一次的时候，
I just remember the huge amounts of frustration because it just wouldn't work it would not install the thing uh because i didn't have a number of other dependencies i needed and then when i tried to install those dependencies it would uninstall some of the other things i had and then i couldn't install the new thing anyway because it depended on two things that were in conflict with each other essentially like these things are a lot better nowadays but back then it was a lot more common because i don't think people appreciated just how vastly huge the open source ecosystem was and was becoming and how much complexity there is in how all these packages depend on each other. It's one of the more complicated graphs that humanity's probably invented, honestly,
I just remember the huge amounts of frustration because it just wouldn't work it would not install the thing uh because i didn't have a number of other dependencies i needed and then when i tried to install those dependencies it would uninstall some of the other things i had and then i couldn't install the new thing anyway because it depended on two things that were in conflict with each other essentially like these things are a lot better nowadays but back then it was a lot more common because i don't think people appreciated just how vastly huge the open source ecosystem was and was becoming and how much complexity there is in how all these packages depend on each other. It's one of the more complicated graphs that humanity's probably invented, honestly,|||我只记得那种巨大的挫败感，因为它就是不工作。它无法安装那个软件，因为我缺少其他好几个必需的依赖项。然后当我试图安装这些依赖项时，它又卸载了我系统里其他的一些东西。接着我还是无法安装那个新软件，因为它依赖于两个互相冲突的东西。本质上，虽然现在这些问题好多了，但在当时要普遍得多，因为我觉得当时人们没有意识到开源生态系统是多么庞大、且正在变得多么庞大，也没有意识到所有这些软件包相互依赖时所产生的复杂度有多高。说实话，这可能是人类创造过的最复杂的图结构之一了，
all the myriad of different things you need in order to start running Node, in order to work on your React project. I mean, Python still has this problem where if you pip install, there's a command where you can add something to your requirements.txt file in python and i think by default it adds the explicit version so it's like okay you want to use my
all the myriad of different things you need in order to start running Node, in order to work on your React project. I mean, Python still has this problem where if you pip install, there's a command where you can add something to your requirements.txt file in python and i think by default it adds the explicit version so it's like okay you want to use my|||为了开始运行 Node、为了进行你的 React 项目，你需要无数种不同的东西。我的意思是，Python 依然存在这个问题：如果你用 pip install，Python 中有一个命令可以让你在 requirements.txt 文件里添加一些东西，而且我认为它默认会添加明确的版本号，所以感觉就像是：“好吧，你想用我的
software you have to be running you know 13.7.3.1 of software xyz and then that means that you can't run my software with anything else because that other thing will now require something it's a little bit off and so that that problem hasn't gone away. I think Node does a good job with the caret equals where they're willing to tolerate minor revisions, but Python still has a problem. That's the way it should be. And that's how we're building T, incidentally, like carets in general. But Node has the advantage as well that JavaScript doesn't mind if you have two versions of a library loaded. It just shadows them. I'm not sure. Yeah, which means it's part
software you have to be running you know 13.7.3.1 of software xyz and then that means that you can't run my software with anything else because that other thing will now require something it's a little bit off and so that that problem hasn't gone away. I think Node does a good job with the caret equals where they're willing to tolerate minor revisions, but Python still has a problem. That's the way it should be. And that's how we're building T, incidentally, like carets in general. But Node has the advantage as well that JavaScript doesn't mind if you have two versions of a library loaded. It just shadows them. I'm not sure. Yeah, which means it's part|||软件，你必须运行 xyz 软件的 13.7.3.1 版本。”这意味着你无法将我的软件与其他任何东西一起运行，因为那个别的东西现在又需要别的版本了。这有点不太对劲。所以这个问题至今还没有消失。我认为 Node 在处理带有尖括号（caret，即 ^）的版本匹配方面做得很好，他们愿意容忍小版本的修订，但 Python 仍然存在这个问题。这才是它本该有的样子。顺便说一句，我们在构建 TXYZ 时也是这么做的，基本上都会用到尖括号。但 Node 的另一个优势在于，JavaScript 并不介意你加载了某个库的两个不同版本，它只是用一个版本把另一个版本给遮蔽（shadow）了。我不确定是不是这样。对，这意味着这也是
of the reason that JavaScript programs can end up with 2000 dependencies, right? Like, because some of them are actually like three or four versions of the same library, because it's been overspent. Oh, my mind is just blown. Yes, it's not really how it should work. But on the other hand, like, it depends on your goals. Like, for me, as I was saying, like, these packaging graphs can become so vast and complicated. Like, developers want to get on with work and chip software. So that really should take priority.
of the reason that JavaScript programs can end up with 2000 dependencies, right? Like, because some of them are actually like three or four versions of the same library, because it's been overspent. Oh, my mind is just blown. Yes, it's not really how it should work. But on the other hand, like, it depends on your goals. Like, for me, as I was saying, like, these packaging graphs can become so vast and complicated. Like, developers want to get on with work and chip software. So that really should take priority.|||JavaScript 程序最终会有 2000 个依赖项的原因之一，对吧？因为其中有些依赖项实际上是同一个库的三四个不同版本，因为它们被过度消耗了。哦，我的天哪，我惊呆了。是的，这确实不是它本该有的运作方式。但从另一方面来看，这取决于你的目标。就像我刚才说的，这些打包依赖图可以变得如此庞大和复杂。开发者们只想继续推进工作并交付软件，所以这才是真正应该被放在首位的。
So the Node way is, like, you know, Node is so huge now. and chip software. So that really should take priority. So the Node way is kind of like, you know, Node is so huge now, easily the most successful tool for programmers of all time. So they made some good choices or NPM did at least in that respect. It's just the programmers in us are like, this is horribly inefficient and disgusting.
So the Node way is, like, you know, Node is so huge now. and chip software. So that really should take priority. So the Node way is kind of like, you know, Node is so huge now, easily the most successful tool for programmers of all time. So they made some good choices or NPM did at least in that respect. It's just the programmers in us are like, this is horribly inefficient and disgusting.|||所以 Node 的方式是——你知道的，Node 现在太庞大了。——并且交付软件。所以这确实应该放在首位。所以 Node 的方式有点像是——你知道的，Node 现在太庞大了，可以说是史上最成功的程序员工具。所以他们在那个方面做出了一些不错的选择，至少 NPM 是这样的。只是我们内心的程序员之魂会觉得：“这简直低效得可怕，太恶心了。”
Yeah, I can't't believe although it makes sense because you know i always wondered you know because because whether someone makes a minor or a major revision is completely arbitrary it's up to the developer to decide this is a minor revision or not so i always wondered how um when i built uh you know websites with node that it more or less just worked and i think you just kind of clarified that for me that you know it's running 10 different versions of bootstrap or whatever yeah they bypass dependency hell and everything you know like a lot of popular languages are still loosely typed but like javascript is like the ultimate loosely typed thing as far as i'm concerned so you might end up with like four versions of this library running and they're
Yeah, I can't't believe although it makes sense because you know i always wondered you know because because whether someone makes a minor or a major revision is completely arbitrary it's up to the developer to decide this is a minor revision or not so i always wondered how um when i built uh you know websites with node that it more or less just worked and i think you just kind of clarified that for me that you know it's running 10 different versions of bootstrap or whatever yeah they bypass dependency hell and everything you know like a lot of popular languages are still loosely typed but like javascript is like the ultimate loosely typed thing as far as i'm concerned so you might end up with like four versions of this library running and they're|||是的，我简直不敢相信。不过这也说得通，因为我以前总是很纳闷——你知道的——因为别人发布的是小版本更新还是大版本更新完全是随意的，这取决于开发者自己决定这算不算小版本更新。所以我一直很好奇，嗯，当我用 Node 构建网站时，为什么它或多或少都能正常运行？我觉得你刚才帮我理清了这一点，原来它同时运行着 10 个不同版本的 Bootstrap 或其他什么库。是的，它们绕过了依赖地狱以及所有这些麻烦。你知道的，许多流行的语言仍然是弱类型的，但就我而言，JavaScript 简直是终极的弱类型事物。所以你的程序里最终可能会同时运行某个库的四个版本，它们
all passing around their own versions of these data structures but because like the code that uses it only checks for the stuff it cares about it generally just works until it doesn't suddenly and spectacularly but you know people can't see this because it's a it's it's an audio show you can't see this but patrick is kind of like uh when that gentleman sees the trash uh on the floor and the single tear rolls down his cheek that's what patrick's looking like right now i don't think any of this would work in embedded no i've run through lots of different languages. I started with C++ because the stuff I was doing in open source and Linux was using Qt. It's called Qt.
all passing around their own versions of these data structures but because like the code that uses it only checks for the stuff it cares about it generally just works until it doesn't suddenly and spectacularly but you know people can't see this because it's a it's it's an audio show you can't see this but patrick is kind of like uh when that gentleman sees the trash uh on the floor and the single tear rolls down his cheek that's what patrick's looking like right now i don't think any of this would work in embedded no i've run through lots of different languages. I started with C++ because the stuff I was doing in open source and Linux was using Qt. It's called Qt.|||各自传递着这些数据结构的各自版本，但因为使用它的代码只检查它关心的东西，所以它通常就是能正常工作——直到它突然以一种极其壮观的方式崩溃。不过你知道，大家看不到这个画面，因为这是一档音频节目，你们看不见，但帕特里克现在的表情就像……就像那位绅士看到地上的垃圾时，一滴眼泪顺着面颊滚落下来一样，帕特里克现在就是这副表情。我觉得这些东西在嵌入式开发里是绝对行不通的。不，我接触过很多不同的语言。我一开始用的是 C++，因为我在开源和 Linux 上做的事情都在使用 Qt。它读作 Qt。
It's a cross-platform toolkit. And Qt made C++ a lot more bearable. But yeah, I've certainly learned that too strong a typing system just gets in the way of getting work done but not enough of a typing system at all means that all you're doing is saying that well this software is not going to work and I don't know how in a couple of weeks in a month there's going to be some bug one of my users is going to suffer for this and uh I'm just okay with that so nowadays i quite like typescript actually because i feel it's like this nice compromise between the loosey-goosey world of javascript and something which has a strong enough type system that when you when you compile it you
It's a cross-platform toolkit. And Qt made C++ a lot more bearable. But yeah, I've certainly learned that too strong a typing system just gets in the way of getting work done but not enough of a typing system at all means that all you're doing is saying that well this software is not going to work and I don't know how in a couple of weeks in a month there's some bug one of my users is going to suffer for this and uh I'm just okay with that so nowadays i quite like typescript actually because i feel it's like this nice compromise between the loosey-goosey world of javascript and something which has a strong enough type system that when you when you compile it you|||这是一个跨平台的工具包。Qt 让 C++ 变得好受多了。不过是的，我确实学到了一点：过于强硬的类型系统只会妨碍你完成工作；但如果完全没有足够的类型系统，那就等于是在说：“好吧，这个软件肯定会出问题，我不知道几周后或一个月后会冒出什么 Bug，我的某个用户将会为此遭殃，而我对此无所谓。”所以现在我其实挺喜欢 TypeScript 的，因为我觉得它是 JavaScript 那种松散自由的世界与具备足够强类型系统的东西之间的一个很好的折中方案。当你编译它时，你
feel that it's done a lot of checking for you probably everything's so we're building a lot of t with typescript using dino oh what is dino i've never heard of that uh do you know it was made by the same guy who made node and it's basically a successor in his mind uh it's an you know an anagram or acronym or whatever it is of node okay so oh interesting oh you have actually i remember reading an article about it but i can't recall the uh oh there was some kind of technical motivations i think maybe around threading maybe i'm sure you would know like why the person forked uh node actually i don't but i'd be very interested to watch talk about it so i must make that happen because i wasn't that into JavaScript until about
感觉它为你做了很多检查，可能一切都是这样。所以我们正在用 TypeScript 和 Dino 构建很多... 哦，什么是 Dino？我从来没听过那个。呃，你知道吗，它是由创造 Node 的同一个人制作的，在他看来，它基本上是 Node 的继任者。呃，你知道的，它是 Node 的一个变位词或首字母缩略词，随便什么都行。好吧，哦，真有趣，哦，实际上我记得读过一篇关于它的文章，但我想不起来... 哦，好像有一些技术动机，我想可能围绕着线程，我敢肯定你会知道这个人为什么会从 Node 分叉（fork）出来。其实我不知道，但我会非常感兴趣地看关于它的讨论，所以我必须实现这一点，因为直到大约
three years ago. So I didn't really care apart from like, I made the brute formula for Node and NPM back in the day and things like that. But yeah, there was, there's certainly limitations with Node. You can, you can tell. And so they threw away a lot of the baggage, you know, in order to make it sort of like a fresh start in many ways. And it has, it has a really nice security system where the programs you write with it,
三年前，我对 JavaScript 还不是那么感兴趣。所以除了... 我以前写过 Node 和 NPM 的底层公式（formula）之类的事情之外，我其实并不太关心。但是，是的，Node 确实存在局限性。你能够，你能够看出来。所以他们抛弃了很多历史包袱，你知道的，为了在很多方面将其作为一个全新的开始。它有一个非常好的安全系统，你用它编写的程序，
you have to opt in explicitly to aspects of the sandbox. So it allows you to have internet, but only if you compile it so it has internet and file system access, et cetera. So you get some security guarantees that are very nice for what we're doing with T. One of the main reasons that we picked it though is because you can compile your typescript into a single binary with no dependencies
你必须显式地选择加入沙盒的各个方面。因此它允许你访问互联网，但前提是你编译它时赋予了它互联网和文件系统访问权限等。所以你得到了一些安全保证，这对于我们用 T 正在做的事情非常友好。不过我们选择它的主要原因之一是因为你可以将你的 typescript 编译成一个没有依赖项的单一二进制文件。
so t is a single binary you can download with no other dependencies like i did this with brew right uh brew you could clone the repository and it worked in the clone it was a working brew system in the end we made an installer because people wanted that. But I'm a believer that with something as fundamental as this kind of developer tooling, every developer has a different preference on how they want it to work. And early adopters, especially, are the ones you want because they're the ones who then evangelize your product. And they want it exactly how they want it.
所以 t 是一个你可以下载的单一二进制文件，没有其他依赖项，就像我用 brew 做的那样。呃，你可以克隆 brew 的仓库，它在克隆版中就能工作，最后它是一个能工作的 brew 系统。我们制作了一个安装程序，因为人们想要它。但我坚信，对于这种基础的开发者工具，每个开发者对于它应该如何工作都有不同的偏好。特别是早期采用者，正是你想要的人，因为他们是随后会宣传你的产品的人。而且他们希望它完全符合他们的心意。
So give them as many choices as you can so to use a single binary compile it for windows linux and mac we have an installer but you don't have to use it it's up to you yeah it's funny you mentioned that i was thinking about with eternal terminal we're still not in the debian uh you know main uh manager we're in all the other ones and the reason is because back in eternal terminal 2 we're up to 7 now i think i don't actually work that much on it anymore myself but i think it's up to version 7 but in version 2 we didn't support fish which is this similar to bash or it's a it's a shell and we didn't support it my developer uses it ah okay cool so so so yeah there's people are really passionate about it and uh i can't remember
所以要尽可能多地给他们提供选择，使用单一二进制文件，为 windows、linux 和 mac 编译它，我们有一个安装程序，但你不必使用它，由你决定。是的，这很有趣，你提到这个，我当时在想，对于 eternal terminal（永恒终端），我们仍然没有进入 debian 的呃，你知道的，主仓库管理器中。我们在所有其他仓库里，原因是因为回到 eternal terminal 2 时，我想我们现在已经到 7 了，其实我自己现在不太参与开发了，但我认为它已经到版本 7 了。但是在版本 2 中，我们不支持 fish，这是一个类似于 bash 的，或者说它是一个 shell，我们当时不支持它，我的开发者在使用它。啊，好吧，酷，所以，所以，是的，有些人对此非常热情，而且呃，我记不清
exactly what happened i think i basically just didn't implement it i don't think i closed the issue honestly i can't remember maybe i did some Phish developer got so upset, and they were also one of the Debian maintainers. And for that reason, you know, half a decade later, we're still not in Debian. So I think it was really a lesson that, you know, the people who are kind of the early adopters, as you said, they're also the people who are the most passionate about, and I think that's true for language inventors as well.
具体发生了什么，我想我基本上就是没实现它。说实话，我不觉得我关闭了这个 issue，我记不清了，也许我关了。某个 Phish 开发者非常生气，而且他们也是 Debian 的维护者之一。正因如此，你知道的，半个世纪后，我们仍然没有进入 Debian。所以我觉得这真的是一个教训，正如你所说，那些早期采用者，他们也是最热情的人，我认为语言发明者也是如此。
You know, to sit down and say, Python and C++ and all these languages, they're not cutting it for me. I'm going to go and invent Rust and spend 10,000 hours evangelizing it. That takes a certain mindset and really good early on to appeal to those people with that mindset, which could be really difficult. Yeah, well, that's a very good point. And it's something that I think a lot more open source projects. When people ask me, how do you make a successful open source project? Appealing to those early adopters is one of the things they say.
你知道，坐下来，然后说，Python 和 C++ 以及所有这些语言，对我来说都不够好。我要去发明 Rust，并花 10,000 小时去推广它。这需要某种心态，并且在早期吸引那些具备这种心态的人真的很好，这可能非常困难。是的，嗯，这是一个很好的观点。而且我认为更多的开源项目都是这样。当人们问我，你如何打造一个成功的开源项目？吸引那些早期采用者就是他们所说的方法之一。
Having a great readme is another thing i spend a lot of time talking about and the t readme i probably spend 10 of my time just crafting that we're not out yet but we're going to be out soon and then i know that when it hits hack and use or twitter or you know slash dot if you can actually still go to slash dot i used to read a lot i don't know if that's a thing anymore actually now i'm curious i think it still exists my shot still exists I used to read a lot of slash. I don't know if that's a thing anymore. Actually, now I'm curious. I think it still exists. Slash. still exists. Yeah. They'll read a blurb, the blurb on slash. say two years, brew two, max hells, make new thing. And then they'll click on the link and they'll go to the readme. So, you know, having a readme that carefully explains to people why they need it, how they can use it, and how easy it is for them to try it out. Very important.
拥有一个出色的 readme 是我花很多时间谈论的另一件事，而 t 的 readme，我可能花了我 10% 的时间来精心打磨它。我们还没发布，但我们很快就会发布，然后我知道当它登上 Hacker News 或 Twitter，或者，你知道的，Slashdot（如果你实际上还能访问 Slashdot 的话。我以前经常阅读，我不知道这现在还存在不存在。实际上，我现在很好奇，我想它仍然存在。我的 Slashdot 仍然存在。我以前经常阅读 Slashdot。我不知道这现在还存在不存在。实际上，我现在很好奇。我想它仍然存在。Slashdot 仍然存在。是的。）他们会阅读简短介绍，Slashdot 上的简短介绍会说：两年，brew 2，mac 地狱，创造新事物。然后他们会点击链接，转到 readme。所以，你知道的，拥有一个仔细向人们解释他们为什么需要它、他们如何使用它以及他们尝试起来有多么容易的 readme 非常重要。
Yeah, that makes sense. So I used to use Mac ports and then I switched to brew. So does Mac ports predate brew or is that just my own personal experience? Okay, yeah. So kind of walk us through that. So Mac ports exist. And at some, you know, MacPorts exists. And at some point you say, I'm going to write Homebrew.
嗯，这说得通。所以我以前用过 Mac ports，然后我换成了 brew。那么 Mac ports 的出现比 brew 早，还是这只是我个人的经历？好的，嗯。那么请给我们讲讲这个过程。所以 Mac ports 存在。在某些，你知道的，MacPorts 存在。然后在某个时刻你说，我要编写 Homebrew。
You know, what's that? What happened there? And what's that journey like? And how did you kind of bring everybody over to Homebrew? Yeah, well, it's a pretty good story. So I use MacPorts like everybody else on Mac. I was at LastFem, which is a music startup, still exists, not really a startup anymore at the time it was.
你知道，那是什么？那里发生了什么？那段历程是怎样的？你是如何把大家都吸引到 Homebrew 过来的？是的，嗯，这是一个相当不错的故事。所以我像 Mac 上的其他人一样使用 MacPorts。我曾在 LastFM 工作，这是一个音乐初创公司，现在还存在，当时它已经算不上真正的初创公司了。
And I was working on the client team because I got the job at LastFem because of open source, my work on open source. I worked on this music player called Amarok for Linux, and it was very popular. It was a pretty good piece of software for Linux anyway. And the people at LastFem loved it. So they asked me if I needed a job. And at the time, I was living in my parents' house for free,
我在客户端团队工作，因为我是通过开源、通过我在开源方面的工作才在 LastFM 找到工作的。我曾为 Linux 参与开发过一款名为 Amarok 的音乐播放器，它非常受欢迎。无论如何，它对于 Linux 来说是一个相当不错的软件。LastFM 的人很喜欢它。所以他们问我需不需要一份工作。当时，我免费住在父母家里，
having finished my chemistry degree, only just passing it because I was so disillusioned with it. And my parents were ready to kick me out of the house for telling me to go get a job. So perfect timing, frankly. I went and got a job because of open source. So I worked on the client apps because that's what I did on Linux. Like we were a website, but we had little apps that you could use to play the music with and scrabble. We had six apps, Windows, Linux and Mac, Android, iPhone and BlackBerry. BlackBerry had an app store
刚刚读完化学学位，因为对它太失望了，所以勉强及格。我父母已经准备把我赶出家门，叫我去找工作了说实话，时机简直太完美了。因为开源，我去找到了一份工作。所以我从事客户端应用程序的开发，因为我在 Linux 上就是做这个的。就像我们有一个网站，但我们有小应用，你可以用来播放音乐和 Scrabble。我们有六个应用，Windows、Linux、Mac、Android、iPhone 和黑莓。黑莓有一个应用商店，
for a very brief time. It was our least favorite app that we made by far horrible horrible sdks and apis but they rushed it they panicked because of the iphone uh so in order to build all these apps we only had a small team we used mac because it was the only platform where the developer tools were pretty good and you could emulate windows and you could emulate linux so we could build for all platforms and then we had all this open source that we used and combining all of that and building it and making it work and then trying to ship and deploy. It was just a nightmare, frankly. I feel that we spent probably 30 to 40% of our time
存在了非常短的时间。这是我们最不喜欢应用，远不及那些糟糕透顶的 SDK 和 API，但他们太匆忙了，因为 iPhone 的出现而惊慌失措。所以为了构建所有这些应用，我们只有一小支团队，我们使用 Mac，因为它是开发工具相当不错的唯一平台，而且你可以模拟 Windows，可以模拟 Linux，这样我们就能为所有平台构建。然后我们使用了所有这些开源软件，将所有这些结合起来构建、让它运行，然后尝试发布和部署。说实话，这简直是一场噩梦。我觉得我们大概有 30% 到 40% 的时间
just messing around with build tools and developer tools and package managers. So I used to complain about the fact that it was tedious work and it was in the way of us getting what we wanted done and one day one of my co-workers got fed up with my complaints and challenged me to do something about it so i went home and started writing the code for homebrew putting together all the ideas i'd had yeah tell folks like uh what was painful about mac ports because
都在瞎折腾构建工具、开发工具和包管理器。所以我过去常常抱怨这项工作很枯燥，它阻碍了我们完成我们想要做的事情。有一天，我的一个同事对我的抱怨忍无可忍，向我发起挑战，让我对此做点什么。于是我回家开始编写 Homebrew 的代码，把我所有的想法整合到一起。是的，给听众们讲讲... Mac ports 痛苦在哪里，因为
a lot of folks listening have probably never even heard of mac ports you know especially if you're just getting started homebrew is really kind of taking the mindshare away so so you know what was mac ports the mac ports experience like back then yeah so um i think the worst part for people back then about MagPorts was that you had to build everything from source. So we were talking about Gentoo just before the show. It was a similar kind of model where you build everything all the way up from LibC, which is basically the fundamental library that all open source and all software in
许多收听的听众可能甚至从来没有听说过 Mac ports，你知道的，特别是如果你刚开始接触的话，Homebrew 确实在某种程度上夺走了人们的心智份额。所以，你知道的，当年的 Mac ports、Mac ports 的体验是怎样的？是的，所以... 嗯，我觉得当年人们对 MacPorts 最痛恨的地方在于你必须从源码构建一切。我们在节目开始前刚刚谈论过 Gentoo。这是一种类似的模式，你必须从 LibC 开始一路向上构建一切，LibC 基本上是所有开源软件和世界上所有软件衍生出来的基础库，
the world derives uh and uh all the way up to whatever you're building and compiling software used to take forever forever because uh these cpus really were very underpowered relatively 20 years ago yeah especially laptops you. They're meant to be small. We had Mac Pros at the time. Oh, nice. The old ones that were even bigger than the cheese grater ones that we've got nowadays. So they had like 16 cores.
一直构建到你正在构建的任何东西。过去编译软件需要花费无休止的时间，因为与 20 年前相比，这些 CPU 的性能确实非常弱。是的，特别是笔记本电脑。它们本该是小巧的。我们当时有 Mac Pro。哦，太棒了。那些比我们现在用的“奶酪刨”还要大的旧型号。所以它们大概有 16 个核心。
They cost like thousands of dollars, but we got them because we were trying to build this software all the time and it took too much time. Even then. So with Mac Pros, you had to build everything software all the time. And it took too much time even then. So with MapPos, you had to build everything from source. Now, the original version of Brew, you had to build everything from source. But I took the very sensible attitude that Apple has already compiled a bunch of these libraries for us.
它们售价好几千美元，但我们买它们是因为我们一直都在试图构建这个软件，这花费了太多时间。即使在当时也是如此。所以有了 Mac Pro，你必须一直从源码构建所有软件。这在当时也花了我太多时间。所以有了 MacPorts，你必须从源码构建一切。现在，Brew 的最初版本，你也必须从源码构建一切。但我采取了一种非常明智的态度，即苹果已经为我们编译好了这些库中的许多。
So let's reuse them. So if you build something like Wget, which is one of the classic uh ways to download things in the terminal like people tend to use curl nowadays because it's more portable and and uh more commonly installed by default but i always use wget as my example with brew it would take five minutes to install it with mac ports it would take three hours so you know yeah what is apple you said apple is already building some things can you dive into that i don't understand yet so uh osx or mac os as we call it now is unix under the hood
所以让我们复用它们。因此，如果你构建像 Wget 这样的东西，它是终端中下载东西的经典方法之一（人们现在倾向于使用 curl，因为它更具可移植性，而且默认安装得更普遍），但我总是用 wget 作为我用 brew 的例子：用 brew 安装它需要五分钟，用 Mac ports 安装它需要三个小时。所以，你知道的，嗯，苹果是什么？你刚才说苹果已经在构建一些东西了，你能详细讲讲吗？我还没听懂。所以... OSX 或 macOS（我们现在这样称呼它）本质上是 Unix，
uh built on top of free bsd originally i think it's free bsd it's one of the bsd yeah that's right and so uh they didn't bundle a package manager, which, of course, you know, we call Brew the missing package manager for Mac for quite a while. But they did bundle a lot of open source. I think people don't realize how much open source that Apple actually do actively support with macOS. But a lot of these fundamental libraries, they're there and also their libraries that they bundle uh the ones they've written that are closed source contain some things that are very useful to open some packages that they can use so macbook is like it macbook took this attitude all right we're just going to ignore the operating system completely we're going to handle everything ourselves and i get that
最初构建在 FreeBSD 之上。我想是 FreeBSD，它是 BSD 家族之一... 是的，没错。所以... 他们没有捆绑包管理器，当然，你知道的，我们在相当长的一段时间里称 Brew 为 Mac 丢失的包管理器。但他们确实捆绑了大量的开源软件。我想人们并没有意识到苹果实际上在 macOS 中积极支持了多少开源软件。但许多这些基础库都在那里，而且他们捆绑的库（即他们编写的闭源库）中包含了一些对打开某些他们可以使用的软件包非常有用的一些东西。所以 MacPorts 的态度是：好吧，我们完全忽略操作系统，我们自己处理一切。我理解这一点，
especially get that now like if i'd known how difficult it is to make a package manager i might have taken their uh choice honestly but i didn't know what i was doing so i built brew with a different idea and one of my favorite quotes about building open source software is by the guy who made php php uh still extremely huge programming language that I doubt anyone who's only learned to program in the last 10 years has ever touched. But he said, he quoted something along the lines of,
特别是现在我懂了：如果我知道制作一个包管理器有多么困难，老实说，我可能会做出他们的选择。但我当时不知道自己在做什么，所以我带着不同的想法构建了 Brew。关于构建开源软件，我最喜欢的一句名言之一来自制作 PHP 的人。PHP 仍然是一个极其庞大的编程语言，我怀疑任何在过去 10 年里才开始学习编程的人是否接触过它。但他说，他引用了类似这样的一句话：
I didn't know what I was doing. I wasn't trying to make a programming language. I just did each part of it as I needed to, step by step. And I think that's how a lot of really big open source projects have come about in time. Because if they knew what they were doing, they would have known that the things they were attempting were difficult, hard, or maybe even considered impossible by experts.
我不知道自己在做什么。我并不是想创造一门编程语言。我只是在需要的时候，一步一步地完成了它的每个部分。我认为这就是许多真正大型开源软件项目随着时间推移而诞生的方式。因为如果他们知道自己在做什么，他们就会知道他们试图做的事情是困难的、艰巨的，甚至可能被专家认为是不可能的。
But they didn't know what they were doing, so they just tried it. And then they made something that got some popularity, so they kept having to hack on it because they felt like an obligation to this community that emerged and certainly what happened with me improved so packaging is hard it turns out and i understand why macports would say okay we're just going to do everything ourselves because then they have control over it but it meant that installing wget took three hours from five minutes and yeah i have a similar story about that. I'd never really used Macs until I became a working professional.
但他们不知道自己在做什么，所以他们就去尝试了。然后他们做出了一些获得一些知名度的东西，所以他们不得不继续对它进行黑客式的修改，因为他们觉得对这个涌现出的社区负有某种责任。这确实就是我在改进 Brew 时发生的情况。所以打包是很困难的，事实证明如此。我理解为什么 MacPorts 会说“好吧，我们只想自己搞定一切”，因为这样他们就能控制它。但这意味着安装 wget 从五分钟变成了三个小时。是的，我也有一个类似的故事。直到我成为一名职业工作者之前，我从未使用过 Mac。
So I'd been Linux pretty much the whole time since high school. I got to my first job and I still had some work to do on my PhD. I think my university needed... There was some issue with LaTeX. So basically, my LaTeX files weren't compiled in the right style and they couldn't print like the dissertations of the year or whatever. They were harassing me about this. So I said, oh, not a big deal.
所以我从高中开始几乎一直都在用 Linux。当我找到第一份工作时，我还有一些关于博士论文的工作要做。我想我的大学需要... LaTeX 存在一些问题。基本上，我的 LaTeX 文件没有用正确的样式编译，他们无法打印当年的毕业论文之类的东西。他们一直在因此而骚扰我。所以我说，哦，这没什么大不了的。
Like I'm just going to open my Mac. I'm going to install like whatever LaTeX program I need on this Mac here while I'm at work. I'm just going to knock this out. And so, yeah, I installed Mac ports. I said, oh oh let me install this mac text and uh mac text it literally took four days i was like port installed mac tech and i came back you know and it's like okay i got some coffee it's still running i did a bunch of work in another tab it's still running it took four days like my my laptop was burning my legs on the bus home
就像我只要打开我的 Mac 一样。我打算在工作时在这台 Mac 上安装我需要的任何 LaTeX 程序。我很快就能把它搞定。所以，是的，我安装了 Mac ports。我说，哦，让我安装这个 MacTeX，呃，MacTeX 真的花了我四天时间。我当时想：port install mactext，然后我回来（你知道的，就像：我喝了杯咖啡，它还在运行；我在另一个标签页里做了很多工作，它还在运行）。它花了我整整四天时间。我的笔记本电脑在回家的公交车上把我的腿都烤烫了。
yeah it was really quite crazy honestly interesting you talk about latex because we um we have a white paper like other crypto projects tend to do and we build it from markdown into a pdf that looks like you know a white paper should. And we're using LaTeX. So we recently have, like, packaged the entire LaTeX stack. And, yeah, it's enormous. It's incredible how much work that has been put into this stuff over the last 30 years because, you know, that's how old these kinds of things are. It's a shame that more people don't use it outside of academia honestly because it is a nice
是的，说实话这真的挺疯狂的。有趣的是，你谈到了 LaTeX，因为我们... 我们有一份白皮书，就像其他加密项目倾向于做的那样，我们用 Markdown 将其构建成一个看起来像（你知道的）白皮书应有的样子的 PDF。我们正在使用 LaTeX。所以我们最近将整个 LaTeX 技术栈打包了。而且，是的，它非常庞大。令人难以置信的是，在过去 30 年里，人们在这类东西上投入了多少工作，因为（你知道的）这些东西就是这么古老。说实话，真遗憾没有更多的人在学术界之外使用它，因为它是一个很好的
documentation format yeah it takes an enormous amount of time to compile but even now even still i think we're into like the 30 to 40 minutes mark now yeah i think there was uh different modes uh i think even in Mac ports, you could specify flags, I think. And there was a minimal flag. I don't know if I could have even used it, though. But yeah, the default just took forever. It's not worth the risk, though, is it? Because it won't have something you need.
文档格式。是的，编译它需要花费大量的时间，但即使现在，我想我们仍然需要大约 30 到 40 分钟的时间。是的，我想有不同的模式... 我想即使在 Mac ports 中，你也可以指定标志（flags），我想是的。还有一个 minimal 标志。不过我不知道我当时是否甚至能用它。但是，是的，默认设置总是需要无休止的时间。不过，不值得冒这个险，不是吗？因为它可能没有你需要的东西。
And then you'll find that you wasted one day rather than four. It doesn't work. Yeah, exactly. Always build with everything. But yeah, Mac ports wasn't bad. It just wasn't great. I think the biggest issues I yeah, MacPulse wasn't bad. It just wasn't great. I think the biggest issues I had with it was it wasn't developer friendly. And I wanted to build a tool that as a developer, I could hack.
然后你会发现你浪费了一天而不是四天。它不管用。是的，完全正确。总是用所有东西构建。但是，是的，Mac ports 也不算坏。它只是不够好。我认为我遇到的最大问题是... 是的，MacPorts 不算坏。它只是不够好。我认为我与它相关的最大问题是它对开发者不友好。我想构建一个作为开发者我可以进行黑客式修改的工具。
I wanted a package manager that I could hack. And so Brew was built from the beginning to be more hackable than any package manager before. I'm sure this is part of the reason it was successful. Even though nowadays, I don't think anyone knows you can hack it. And a lot of the hackable features have been removed by the current maintainers over the years because they made it more difficult to maintain.
我想要一个我可以进行魔改的包管理器。所以 Brew 从一开始就被构建得比以往任何包管理器都更容易魔改。我确信这是它成功的原因之一。尽管现在，我认为没有人知道你可以对它进行魔改。多年来，许多可魔改的功能已被当前的维护者移除，因为这使得维护变得更加困难。
But yeah, they were cool features, and T's going to have all of them. Yeah, that makes sense. I love how easy it is to add repos. That was one thing. I know with Debianbian, this gets back to Eternal Terminal, you know, when people want to use ET on Debian, you know, they have to copy this really long string and it requires sudo. And so they don't really know what it's going to do to their computer. I think it just it adds some GPG key or something from the internet. But then they have to run update, and now it does something different. And it's just really complicated. With Brew, it's BrewTap, right?
但是，是的，这些都是很酷的功能，而 T 将拥有所有这些功能。是的，这说得通。我喜欢添加仓库（repo）是多么容易。那是其中一件事。我知道对于 Debian，这回到了 Eternal Terminal，你知道的，当人们想在 Debian 上使用 ET 时，你知道的，他们必须复制这串非常长的字符串，并且它需要 sudo。所以他们其实并不知道它会对他们的电脑做什么。我想它只是从互联网上添加了一些 GPG 密钥之类的东西。但随后他们必须运行 update，现在它做了一些不同的事情。这真的很复杂。而对于 Brew，它是 BrewTap，对吧？
BrewTap and then the place. I think it's integrated with GitHub, right? So BrewTap, the organization name, the repo name, and GitHub, and you're done. You're good. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Like, that was certainly one thing I wanted to do with Brew that I felt that very few of the other package managers had
BrewTap 然后是位置。我想它与 GitHub 集成了，对吧？所以 BrewTap，组织名称，仓库名称，以及 GitHub，这就完成了。这就好了。是的。是的。是的，是的。就像，这绝对是我在 Brew 中想要做的一件事，我觉得很少有其他包管理器能够做到这一点：
is make it easy to use and fun to use. Like, get out of your way so you as someone who really doesn't care how the package manager works or what it's for in many ways can just get the software they want installed easily and quickly. And yeah, the taps thing, it was always my plan to make it so that other people could maintain packages outside of what we were maintaining. I didn't really develop that idea very much because it turned out maintaining Groove by itself was a full-time job.
让它易于使用且有趣。就像，不要挡你的路，这样作为一个其实并不在乎包管理器如何工作或它有什么用处的人，你可以简单快速地安装你想要的软件。是的，taps 这个功能，我一直的计划是让其他人能够在我们维护的内容之外维护软件包。我并没有真正深入发展这个想法，因为事实证明，单单维护 Brew 就是一份全职工作。
So someone else in the end came up with the name Taps and the idea for Taps, but I rejected their idea and did it differently, which caused the person who did this contribution to quit the project. Oh, no. Well, it happened. Yeah. But I was right because their idea for Taps, right, it would explore the fork graph of Homebrew
所以最后另一个人想出了 Taps 这个名字和 Taps 的想法，但我拒绝了他们的想法并用了不同的做法，这导致做出这个贡献的人退出了项目。哦，不。好吧，事情就是这样。是的。但我是对的，因为他们关于 Taps 的想法（对吧）会遍历 Homebrew 的分叉图（fork graph），
and search for formula in the fork graph and then install them. So, you know, on GitHub, you fork projects and then you can add stuff. So this was really good in many ways as an idea, and I've used this idea for other things since then, because open source should, GitHub as a whole, should focus more on forks
并在分叉图中搜索公式然后安装它们。所以，你知道的，在 GitHub 上，你可以分叉（fork）项目，然后你可以添加东西。所以这个想法在很多方面都非常好，从那以后我也在其他事情上使用过这个想法，因为开源应当... GitHub 作为一个整体，应该更多地关注分叉，
that's some good work that gets done in forks and people never find out about them and open source is all about other people starting to work on these projects but anyway this isn't a site uh but i didn't feel that people would be able to trust the tool if it could just install a formula like randomly found in the fork tree without some kind of reputation system and i felt that this would be bad for brew and for the user so instead i changed it so you had to explicitly add tabs and then they were like repositories full of categorized formula effectively maybe it would just be someone who is passionate about these few projects or maybe it's like an organization or an entire uh open source uh project that maintains multiple
有些优秀的工作是在分叉中完成的，而人们却从未发现它们，开源就是关于其他人开始致力于这些项目的。总之，这不是一个网站... 但我不觉得人们能够信任这个工具，如果它能直接安装一个在分叉树中随机找到的公式，而没有某种声誉系统的话。我觉得这对 Brew 和用户来说都是不好的。所以我改变了它，要求你必须显式添加 taps，然后它们实际上变成了充满分类公式的仓库。可能只是某个人对这几个项目充满热情，或者它是一个组织，或者是维护多个不同包的整个开源项目。
different packages and with hindsight that was definitely the right choice because that's how people have used them uh you you find the tap and you trust the person who's telling you about the tap rather than it being some sort of random thing. The original idea was more open source, but it was risky. So yeah, it was always planned to do something like that. And that's because I wanted it to be more like that. Like Mac ports, I tried to contribute to Mac ports once and I couldn't even figure out how.
事后看来，这绝对是正确的选择，因为这就是人们使用它们的方式：你找到了 tap，并且你信任告诉你关于这个 tap 的人，而不是让它成为某种随机的东西。最初的想法更具开源精神，但它风险很大。所以，是的，一直都有计划做类似的事情。那是因为我希望它更像是那样。就像 Mac ports，我曾经尝试为 Mac ports 做贡献，甚至连怎么做都弄不明白。
So I wanted to build a tool that you didn't need to figure out how. It could just like automatically bring in other people's contributions as long as they okayed it. So yeah, it was always a goal. Developer experience, user experience. I'm super passionate about both
所以我想要构建一个你不需要去琢磨怎么用的工具。只要他们批准，它就可以自动引入其他人的贡献。所以，是的，这一直是一个目标。开发者体验，用户体验。我对这两者都充满热情。
of those things. Yeah, that makes sense. We just had some core Ruby developers on the show. And what inspired you to use Ruby for the formula? Yeah, I love Ruby. I've only recently realized how much I miss it. Because the only thing I've ever been able to use it for was Homebrew.
这说得通。我们刚刚在节目中邀请了一些核心 Ruby 开发者。是什么启发你使用 Ruby 来编写公式的？是的，我热爱 Ruby。我直到最近才意识到我是多么想念它。因为我唯一能使用它的地方就是 Homebrew。
So I picked Ruby for a few reasons. One, I wanted Homebrew to just work on Mac without any messing around. So I wanted, as a result, to pick a scripting language because I wanted people to be able to clone Homebrew and then it immediately just works. There's no compilation step. There's no build system stuff that you have to do. Because at the time, especially, it was extremely common that you couldn't use any software without building it first so you were completely dependent on package managers so you would like find out about a new project and then you go to the website and you'd find
所以我选择 Ruby 有几个原因。第一，我希望 Homebrew 能够在 Mac 上直接运行，而不需要任何胡乱折腾。因此，作为结果，我想选择一种脚本语言，因为我希望人们能够克隆 Homebrew，然后它就能立即运行。没有编译步骤。没有你必须做的构建系统方面的东西。因为特别是当时，非常普遍的情况是，如果不先构建它，你就无法使用任何软件，所以你完全依赖于包管理器。因此，你会发现一个新项目，然后你访问网站，却发现
that your package manager that you were using didn't support it yet so then you have to decide whether or not you were going to like figure out how to make the thing work which would take hours or just like not use the thing at all and wait until it appeared in your package of choice yeah i still have this problem today there's a um you know in wi-fi you have the 2.4g and the 5g wi-fi right in linux it's really hard to find a wi-Fi adapter that's 5G that works in Linux. And I found one where I had to build a kernel module from the source. The whole thing took me multiple hours. And then as soon as I upgraded the OS, it stopped working. So finally, I was like, forget it.
你正在使用的包管理器还不支持它。所以你必须决定是花几个小时弄清楚如何让这个东西工作，还是干脆不用这个东西，一直等到它出现在你首选的包管理器中。是的，我今天仍然有这个问题。有一个... 你知道，在 Wi-Fi 中，你有 2.4G 和 5G Wi-Fi，对吧？在 Linux 中，很难找到一个在 Linux 下工作的 5G Wi-Fi 适配器。我找到过一个，我不得不从源码构建一个内核模块。整个过程花了我好几个小时。然后我一升级操作系统，它就停止工作了。所以最后我想，算了，
I'm going to get a 2.4G SSID up in the house just because of that. So it's still a problem today. It's such a familiar story. 2.4G SSID up in the house just because of that. So it's still a problem today. It's such a familiar story. It's why I rage quit Linux actually was like the seventh time in several months where I didn't have any working Wi-Fi and I had no other internet. So I was just sitting there trying to figure this out by myself. And then I was like like apple just released an intel mac and uh osx looks like it's unix but prettier and with some user experience considerations
我直接在家里弄一个 2.4G SSID 算了，就因为这个。所以这个问题今天依然存在。这是一个如此熟悉的故事。就在家里弄一个 2.4G SSID 算了，就因为这个。所以这个问题今天仍然存在。这是一个如此熟悉的故事。这也是我愤而怒退 Linux 的原因，实际上这是几个月内的第七次，我没有工作的 Wi-Fi，也没有其他互联网。所以我只是坐在那里试图自己弄清楚这一点。然后我想... 苹果刚刚发布了一台英特尔 Mac，而 OSX 看起来就像是 Unix，但更漂亮，并且考虑了一些用户体验，
so i bought one and never looked back i obviously use linux a lot like a lot of people do nowadays but only as a server and not as a desktop right oh yeah same thing i i have a hard time uh i tried the linux laptop thing back in 2018 i was like oh by now it's got to be a better experience and i was i was back to macbook in six months yeah i haven't i haven't looked into desktop linux in years but i have a friend who recently switched, well, a couple of years ago now. He's been doing this a couple of years still, from Mac to Linux.
所以我买了一台，从此再也没有回头。当然，我经常使用 Linux，就像现在很多人一样，但仅限于作为服务器，而不是作为桌面端。哦，对，一样。我很难... 我在 2018 年尝试过 Linux 笔记本电脑这回事，我当时想：到现在为止，这总得是一种更好的体验了吧。结果我六个月后又换回了 MacBook。是的，我已经好几年没有关注桌面端 Linux 了，但我有一个朋友最近（嗯，现在是几年前了）从 Mac 切换到了 Linux。
It's because mostly he got fed up with Apple, which I get. The guy worked for Apple for years ago, so he had a better understanding, I think, than most people about them and what they're doing. But he decided that what was going on with OS X and iPhone and all that was just not worth it for him anymore, so he switched back to Linux. And he's doing all right.
主要是因为他对苹果厌烦了，我能理解。这家伙几年前曾在苹果工作过，所以我想他比大多数人更了解苹果以及他们在做什么。但他决定，OSX、iPhone 和所有这些正在发生的事情对他来说已经不值得了，所以他切换回了 Linux。他现在过得还不错。
He doesn't complain, at least. But I think he was politically motivated to a reasonable extent. Yeah, I think if you're motivated, you can do anything. I couldn't get the Thprint uh you know the thumbprint login to work and they're like oh you know the company that releases the thumbprint this is a dell it's not even like a random brand and they're like try building it from source it didn't compile so the thumbprint never worked yeah god you bring back a lot of memories you know like it's basically these kinds of frustrations
至少他没有抱怨。但我认为他在很大程度上是出于政治动机。是的，我想如果你有动力，你可以做到任何事。我无法让指纹（登录）... 你知道，指纹登录正常工作。他们说：哦，你知道，发布指纹的这家公司，这是一台戴尔电脑，甚至都不是什么随机品牌。他们说：尝试从源码构建它。它没有编译成功，所以指纹功能从来没用过。上帝啊，你勾起了我太多的回忆，你知道的，基本上就是这些类型的挫折
that drove me to doing homebrew it's like i want all this stuff to get out of the way because like oh at the end of the day i like making other things and i like playing around with new things i love new tools and apps and utilities that people build in open source and i want to try them out i was like i just want like the whole bit that's difficult to get out of the way so yeah i built it from the start and throughout with those being guiding philosophies for how it should work like the people who did join the project and now maintain it in my absence i drilled it into them like quite thoroughly and maybe even like unpleasantly that the most important thing was that Homebrew was robust, that it worked, that it got the user what they wanted.
驱使我去做 Homebrew。这就像：我希望所有这些东西都别来烦我，因为归根结底，我喜欢制作其他东西，我喜欢玩新事物。我热爱人们在开源中构建的新工具、应用和实用程序，我想尝试它们。我当时想：我只希望这整个困难的部分滚开。所以，是的，我从一开始就构建了它，并将这些作为它应如何运作的指导哲学贯穿始终。那些加入项目并在我不在时维护它的人，我向他们灌输了这一点，相当彻底，甚至可能有些令人不快：最重要的是 Homebrew 必须健壮，它必须工作，它必须把用户想要的东西给他们。
And so we spent a lot of time on error messages and stuff. Your experience with compiling your Wi-Fi driver. The problem was the error messages didn't help you to figure out what to do about it, right? Yeah. If they could have been more useful, then probably you would have been able to figure about it right yeah if they could have been more useful then probably you would have been able to figure it out and then it would have been a minor frustration rather than the major frustration that made you abandon even trying to do it and
所以我们在错误消息等方面花了很多时间。你编译 Wi-Fi 驱动程序的经历，问题在于错误消息并没有帮你弄清楚该怎么做，对吧？是的。如果它们更有用的话，你可能就能弄清楚了。是的，如果它们更有用的话，你可能就能弄清楚了，那就会是一个小挫折，而不是让你甚至放弃尝试的主大挫折，
so with homebrew the error is always like attempting to be helpful and then we built like the doctor command into it so doctor like tries to diagnose what might be wrong with your system for you and give you helpful tidbits. Then direct you to stuff on GitHub that might be able to help you. We used to make it so that when the build failed, we'd search GitHub for you and see if we could find where someone else had already had the same issue. So maybe you could get some help there. Well, I believe that people can fix these problems themselves. It's just we're the experts, and we need to give as much automated help as possible
所以对于 Homebrew，错误信息总是试图提供帮助，然后我们将 doctor 命令内置其中。所以 doctor 会尝试为你诊断系统可能出现的问题，并为你提供有用的提示。然后将你引导到 GitHub 上可能对你有所帮助的内容。我们过去常常这样做：当构建失败时，我们会为你搜索 GitHub，看看能否找到其他人已经遇到相同问题的地方。这样你也许能从那里得到一些帮助。嗯，我相信人们可以自己解决这些问题。只是我们是专家，我们需要提供尽可能多的自动化帮助，
because we don't have enough time to do it by hand. That makes sense. So when you install Homebrew, I'm assuming it installs a Ruby VM and interpreter because I don't think that comes built in on Mac, right? And then how does that work? That was one of the reasons I chose Ruby is that it came with the Mac.
因为我们没有足够的时间手动去做。这说得通。所以当你安装 Homebrew 时，我假设它安装了一个 Ruby 虚拟机和解释器，因为我不认为那是 Mac 预装的，对吧？然后那是怎么运作的？这也是我选择 Ruby 的原因之一，因为它随 Mac 一起附带。
And I think it's still done. Oh, I didn't know that. Yeah, it's like an older version now. And so, you know, Brew had to like maintain compatibility with this older version for a long time, probably still does. But yeah, it came with it.
我想现在依然如此。哦，我不知道。是的，现在它是一个较旧的版本。所以，你知道的，Brew 不得不在很长一段时间里保持与这个旧版本的兼容性，可能现在依然如此。但是，是的，它随系统附带。
So yeah, I picked Ruby because it came with the Mac. I wanted brew to be this thing that just easily installed and just worked immediately without any messing around no installer no build systems and uh i wanted to try out ruby i'd heard great things about how great ruby was uh ruby on rails was like relatively nascent this was like 2007 2000 that was 2009 2009 and uh you know i read some tutorials about ruby and it like looked beautiful and like frankly it is i i miss it because you know i've been doing tea i've been packaging with tea and so i ended up doing some ruby again i'm like ah it's beautiful nice so what is beautiful what's beautiful about ruby
所以，是的，我选择了 Ruby，因为它随 Mac 附带。我希望 brew 能成为这样一种东西：能够轻松安装并且立即正常工作，没有任何胡乱折腾，没有安装程序，没有构建系统，而且... 我想尝试 Ruby，我听说过很多关于 Ruby 有多棒的好话，Ruby on Rails 相对处于萌芽期，这是 2007 年... 2000 年，那是 2009 年，2009 年，而且，你知道的，我读了一些关于 Ruby 的教程，它看起来很美，坦白说它确实很美。我很怀念它，因为，你知道的，我一直在做 t，我一直在用 t 打包，所以我最后又写了一些 Ruby，我心想：啊，太美了，真好。那么什么是美的？Ruby 美在哪里？
it's just so elegant there's there's a way to do everything in ruby that i used to spend hours rewriting my code just to make it more pretty because i could i knew i always knew there was a prettier way to express it in ruby and you know like the primitives are great. Just today with TypeScript, I was annoyed there's no zip function, for example. There's just not enough functional primitives that come with TypeScript or
它就是那么优雅。在 Ruby 中做每件事都有这样一种方法，我过去常常花上几个小时重写代码，只为了让它更漂亮，因为我可以。我知道，我总是知道在 Ruby 中有一种更漂亮的表达方式，而且，你知道的，基本类型非常好。就在今天使用 TypeScript 时，我很烦恼，例如没有 zip 函数。TypeScript 或 JavaScript 自带的函数式基本类型不够多。
JavaScript. You can get libraries that do these things, but then they don't have enough language built-ins to make it so that it works nicely. So I don't like using the libraries, and I just avoid using zip and things like that as a result. But Ruby's standard library was really nicely designed.
你可以获得做这些事情的库，但它们没有足够的语言内置功能来让它很好地工作。所以我不喜欢使用这些库，结果我只好避免使用 zip 之类的方法。但 Ruby 的标准库设计得真的很好。
And some of the little features, like they'd borrow a few things from Perl, but not too much, so that it was a nightmare. And then you could, you know, the one-liner type input system from Perl, but not too much so that it was a nightmare. And then you could the one-liner type input system from Perl so you can write little scripts that will take inputs from the command line
还有一些小功能，比如它们从 Perl 那里借用了几样东西，但又没有借用太多以至于变成一场噩梦。然后你可以... 你知道的，来自 Perl 的单行代码式输入系统，但又没有那么多以至于变成噩梦。然后你可以使用来自 Perl 的单行代码式输入系统，这样你就可以编写小脚本，从命令行获取输入，
and then work on them seamlessly and then automatically print outputs. So you could write these really tight little scripts and it just felt so good to use but yeah I couldn't write T in it because I need a type system
然后无缝地对它们进行处理，并自动打印输出。所以你可以编写这些非常紧凑的小脚本，使用起来感觉太棒了。但是，是的，我无法用它编写 T，因为我需要一个类型系统。
nowadays I've learned I learned without a type system and then my first set of professional open source work was C++ which is too typed and too unpleasant in many other ways then everyone was super passionate about things like Ruby and JavaScript and Python,
现在我已经学会了。我一开始是在没有类型系统的情况下学习的，然后我的第一批专业开源工作是 C++，它在很多其他方面都过于强调类型且令人不快。然后每个人都对 Ruby、JavaScript 和 Python 这样的东西充满热情，
because suddenly you weren't spending all this time with the type system in your way. I think things like TypeScript have got the right balance between allowing you to escape from it and be able to do reasonably good code when you need to without the type system constraining you. But also the type system is really nice and fast. God, it's fast because I used Swift for quite a few years
因为突然之间，你不再把所有这些时间花在阻碍你的类型系统上了。我认为像 TypeScript 这样的东西在允许你摆脱它以及在需要时能够编写出相当好的代码（而不会受到类型系统束缚）之间取得了正确的平衡。而且类型系统也确实非常棒且快速。天哪，它非常快，因为我用了好几年的 Swift，
because I was quite an iPhone developer for quite some time. So I became super passionate about Swift. I wrote a bunch of open source tooling for Swift. But it takes so long to build a Swift program. Right. Similar to Scala. Scala has the same problem. Like, as a developer, you need these fast debug cycles, because otherwise you
因为我在相当长的一段时间里是一名坚定的 iPhone 开发者。所以我对 Swift 充满了热情。我为 Swift 编写了一堆开源工具。但构建一个 Swift 程序需要花很长时间。没错。类似于 Scala。Scala 也有同样的问题。作为一个开发者，你需要这些快速的调试循环，否则你
lose what you're doing. Your brain can only hold on to all that context for so long. Yeah, I mean, I was in some C++ templating hellscape about a week ago. And it's interesting. I mean, there's auto now.
就会失去你正在做的事情。你的大脑只能在有限的时间内保持所有这些上下文。是的，我的意思是，大约一周前我正处于某个 C++ 模板地狱中。这很有趣。我的意思是，现在有了 auto。
And so there's type inferencing and all of that, which definitely helps. I mean, you see auto everywhere now. But occasionally you will still end up with some just complete template nightmare. Here's what I think the problem is with C++ is that people, you know, people will use pound defines and templates because they don't,
所以有了类型推断和所有这些，这绝对有帮助。我的意思是，你现在到处都能看到 auto。但偶尔你还是会落入某种完全的模板噩梦中。我认为 C++ 的问题在于人们（你知道的）会使用宏定义（pound define）和模板，因为他们不...
instead of using correct design patterns. So like, for example, you know, you could do dependency injection and inject a clock into your class. And so now you have a system clock, you have a fake clock, and you can inject any clock into your class. And so now you have a system clock, you have a fake clock, and you can inject any clock you want. Or you could have a template,
而不是使用正确的设计模式。比如，你知道的，你可以进行依赖注入，将时钟（clock）注入到你的类中。所以现在你有一个系统时钟，你有一个模拟时钟，你可以将任何时钟注入到你的类中。所以现在你有一个系统时钟，你有一个模拟时钟，你可以注入任何你想要的时钟。或者你可以有一个模板，
which takes like a class clock. And now like that entire code base needs to be in the header file. And like everywhere you use that class, you have to do bracket, you know, my clock, except when you're in a test. And now, you know, so it's just people use templates
它接收一个类时钟。现在整个代码库都需要在头文件中。而且你在哪里使用这个类，你就必须写尖括号（你知道的），我的时钟，除非你在测试中。现在，你知道的，所以这只是人们滥用模板
in ways that create landmines, I think. Oh, absolutely. I remember many times having similar issues. And I remember those template errors that could be like three or four pages of compiler output. And like figuring out what the error was. Like Q was nice in that respect. They understood that like C++ standard library
我觉得这会以创造地雷的方式发生。哦，绝对是这样。我记得有很多次遇到过类似的问题。我还记得那些模板错误，编译器输出能有三四页长。要去弄清楚错误到底是什么。在这方面，Q 相对来说还不错。他们理解 C++ 标准库
just went over the top and needed to be discarded. So they did their own. I remember having fun with macros. I edited a co-worker's header file at one point and put hash error at the top. And as a result, every single thing you tried to do with error and because of the way the c++ compiler did or maybe i did a trick of some sort it didn't say where the error was
简直是太过分了，必须被抛弃。所以他们做了自己的标准库。我记得玩宏玩得很开心。我曾在某个时候修改了一个同事的头文件，并在顶部加了 #error。结果，你尝试用 error 去做的每一件事，由于 C++ 编译器的机制——或者可能是我用了某种技巧——它不会显示错误是在
happening and i let him like try to debug it for like 20 minutes before i walked over and like fixed it for him but yeah you could you could really do like evil things it's from an era where you know developers just believe that other developers needed to be able to like wade in there put on their big boots and figure it out but you know we made the right choices by realizing that that wasn't actually a good use of developers time at the end of the day we're trying to improve the world with software and if we're wasting time finding like a prank that your co-worker put in because it was possible it's not good a great april fool's uh prank out there if you're listening to this show and want to know a good april fool's prank yeah you pat if you're in C++, you pound define and replace if with if, you know,
哪里发生的，然后我让他试着调试了大约 20 分钟，之后我才走过去帮他修好了。不过真的，你确实可以做一些很邪恶的事。这来自一个那样的时代，你知道，开发者就是坚信其他开发者需要能够深入其中、穿上厚重的靴子自己去搞清楚。但你知道，我们通过意识到这其实并不是对开发者时间的充分利用，从而做出了正确的选择。归根结底，我们正试图用软件让世界变得更好，如果我们把时间浪费在寻找同事由于觉得好玩而留下的恶作剧上，那可真是不太好。这倒是一个很棒的愚人节恶作剧。如果你正在听这个节目，想知道一个好的愚人节恶作剧，是的，帕特，如果你在用 C++，你可以用 #define 把 if 替换成 if，你知道的，
rand is greater than 0.999 and the actual if statement. And so you've created your own quantum computer. And so now you have this beautiful quantum computer that you can use, and it'll run for about an hour or so. Yeah, man. It's just crazy, isn't it, that the language allowed you to literally do a
只要 rand 大于 0.999 加上实际的 if 语句。于是你就创造了你自己的量子计算机。现在你就有了一台可以使用的美丽的量子计算机，它大概能运行一个小时左右。天哪。这真是太疯狂了，不是吗？这个语言竟然允许你对关键字进行字面的
string replace on keywords and you wouldn't know. You'd have to dig really deep to find that. And like, yeah, we all found open source projects or other people's code where people were doing this stuff with C++. It needs to die. Rust is fabulous in relation.
字符串替换，而你却毫无察觉。你得挖得很深才能发现这一点。而且，是的，我们都发现过开源项目或其他人的代码，里面有人在 C++ 中搞这种把戏。这种做法必须消亡。相比之下，Rust 简直太棒了。
Did you hear about Rust going into the Linux kernel? I was very excited about that. That happened earlier this week. Yeah, we're recording the show in September. So yeah, this just happened. So I'm really excited about that. Yeah, it's so good. It needs to happen to all the base level
你听说 Rust 进入 Linux 内核的事了吗？我对此感到非常兴奋。这周早些时候发生的。对，我们是在九月份录制这个节目。所以，是的，这刚刚发生。所以我真的超级兴奋。太棒了，所有的底层
things and the Linux kernel will only benefit, in my opinion. I'm sure there'll be some teething troubles for a while, but I want to see things like OpenSSL replaced with Rust equivalents over the next five to ten years.
东西都应该这样做，在我看来，Linux 内核只会从中受益。我确信会有一些阵痛期，但我希望看到像 OpenSSL 这样的东西在未来五到十年内被 Rust 的同类替代品所取代。
The entire security and robustness of everything we've built uh needs it yeah can you imagine when you replace open ssl with a rust version and find you know 3 000 exploits yeah that would that would be a fun thing to read about so i mean i hope someone's doing it i think i think i've read that some people are yeah a lot of open ssl code is is pretty gnarly because it's it's like um it's c that they're compiling with a c++ compiler you know but it but it's a bunch of global functions that are taking classes as objects and everything so it's going to be a brutal yeah it's a brutal port but someone will do it it's an important enough library
我们建造的一切的安全性和健壮性都需要它。是的，你能想象当你用 Rust 版本替换 OpenSSL 并发现，你知道的，3000 个漏洞时会发生什么吗？是的，那读起来一定是一件很有趣的事。所以，我的意思是，我希望有人正在这样做。我想我读到过有些人确实在这么做。是的，很多 OpenSSL 代码都相当难啃，因为它是……呃，它是用 C++ 编译器编译的 C 代码，但它又是一堆把类当作对象来调用的全局函数等等。所以这将是一个残酷的……是的，这是一个残酷的移植，但总会有人去做的，毕竟这是一个足够重要的库。
oh yeah it's foundational and it's interesting in the respect that it's like 20-30 years old at this point and like it's full of very well tested but still buggy code it's a testament to how bad I think humans
哦，是的，它是基础性的。而且有趣的是，它现在已经有 20 到 30 年的历史了，里面充满了经过充分测试但依然充满 bug 的代码。这证明了人类在编程这件事上
are at programming and why we need tooling to support us yeah totally so what is um like the most kind of uh crazy experience you've had with homebrew like what's a what's an incredibly complicated situation you've had to deal with it could be you know arguments over a package or or some really esoteric error or what's something that kind of really kept you up at night when you're doing homebrew well i certainly did have sleepless nights at various times because it became important and worrying about whether or not i was taking it in the right direction, it mattered to me.
到底有多糟糕，以及为什么我们需要工具来支持我们。完全同意。那么，关于 Homebrew，你经历过最疯狂的事情是什么？——你处理过的最极其复杂的情况是什么？这可能你知道是一个关于某个包的争论，或者是一些非常深奥的错误，又或者是什么事情在你使用 Homebrew 的时候真的让你彻夜难眠？好吧，我在不同时期确实经历过不眠之夜，因为它变得很重要，而且我担心自己是否把它带向了正确的方向，这对我来说很重要。
Some people think I'm not a very nice person, but I genuinely care about these bits of open source I put out there and how it impacts the world and what the world is going to get out. I think the reason I'm not considered nice in some ways is that guy who committed the project over the taps thing. I just stood my ground. I stood my ground. I was like, I don't think it should be ways is like that guy who quit the project over the taps thing, right? I just took my ground. I was like, I don't think it should be this way. We need to do it this other way. And it's, it's hard to have like,
有些人觉得我不是个很好的人，但我真心关切我发布的这些开源代码片段，以及它如何影响世界，世界将从中获得什么。我想我在某些方面不被认为是好人的原因，就像那个因 taps 问题而退出项目的家伙一样。我只是坚持了我的立场。我坚持了我的立场。我说过，我不认为事情应该是……方式是——就像那个因 taps 问题而退出项目的家伙一样，对吧？我只是坚守立场。我说过，我不认为事情应该这样。我们需要用另一种方式来做。而且，这很难接受，
especially if you put work into something rejected in that manner. So, you know, I felt like a bad person a lot, but my priority by far was the product, the thing that we were building and how that impacted open source and how that impacted the entire software ecosystem all developers of any kind so you know that that's stuff like that i remember like stories like you know when we put node in we bundled npn with it and then isaac didn't want that so he came up and we argued for like several days about whether or not it was
特别是如果你把心血投入到某样东西中，却遭到那样的拒绝。所以，你知道，我经常觉得自己是个坏人，但我的首要任务绝对是产品，也就是我们正在构建的东西，以及它如何影响开源，如何影响整个软件生态系统——所有各种各样的开发者。所以，你知道，诸如此类的事情。我还记得一些故事，比如，当我们把 node 放进去时，我们将 npm 与它捆绑在一起，然后 Isaac 不想要那样，于是他找上门来，我们争论了好几天，争论到底是不是
Homebrew's job to bundle NPN with Node or not and in the end we agreed we agreed with them you know that was something that we tried to do with Brew as well it's like we weren't we didn't consider us to be the most important part of the ecosystem we were just like the middleware
Homebrew 的工作把 NPN 和 Node 捆绑在一起。最后我们同意了，我们同意了他们的看法，你知道，这也是我们在 Brew 上尝试做的事情。这就好比我们不认为自己是生态系统中最重要的部分，我们只是中间件，
between the people who knew what their open source should do because they're building it and the users who wanted to do something with it. I think a lot of these packages, they take the attitude that they're building the system and what matters most is them. And
存在于那些知道自己的开源应该做什么的人（因为他们在构建它）和那些想要用它做点什么的用户之间。我认为很多这样的软件包都有一种态度，即它们在构建系统，而最重要的是它们自己。
I don't agree with that. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I think everything you build has an audience and you need to kind of understand and iterate. There was some issue with Eternal Terminal early on where we have an auto opt-in. There is an error, or not an error message, but there's a little message and delay the first time.
我不同意这一点。是的，这说得通。是的，我认为你构建的任何东西都有受众，你需要去理解并进行迭代。早期关于 Eternal Terminal 有一些问题，我们有一个自动选择加入（auto opt-in）功能。有一个错误，或者说不是错误消息，而是在第一次时有一个小消息和延迟。
We have an auto opt-in to Sentry so we can collect crashes. And that was a really difficult kind of decision to make, because, you know, I do really respect people's privacy. And we're very careful not to log someone's IP address or anything like that. But even still, like, you know, logging, you know, a crash stack, so it makes some people nervous, it was a difficult decision. But then on the flip side, like I constantly getting issues like, hey, here's a crash. And there's no way to repro. And we don't have all the artifacts. It's just gone.
我们默认加入了 Sentry 以便能够收集崩溃信息。这是一个非常艰难的决定，因为，你知道，我真的很尊重大家的隐私。我们非常小心，不会记录某人的 IP 地址或类似的信息。但即便如此，你知道，记录崩溃堆栈会让一些人感到紧张，这是一个艰难的决定。但另一方面，我不断收到这样的问题：“嘿，这里有个崩溃。”而根本无法复现。我们也没有所有的工件。它就这样消失了。
It's difficult. You're caught in a space. You can't make everyone happy. So you're always kind of a mean person to somebody. But as long as you're a nice person to somebody else at the same time, it works out. I got some stories about crash reporting with Amarok, the music player.
这很难。你夹在中间。你无法让每个人都满意。所以你对某人来说总是显得有点刻薄。但只要你同时对其他人好一点，结果就行得通。我有一些关于 Amarok（那个音乐播放器）崩溃报告的故事。
It was very crashy because all of us were relatively junior developers, frankly, at the time. So I built in a thing where if it crashed, it opened up your email client with crashes at Amarok.org with the backtrace in it. And I felt this was a nice compromise there. Like they choose whether or not they're going to send it. And we've made it very simple for them because we grabbed the backtrace and stuck it in an email and they understand how email works.
它经常崩溃，坦白说，因为当时我们所有人相对来说都是初级开发者。所以我内置了一个功能，如果它崩溃了，它会打开你的电子邮件客户端，收件人是 crashes@amarok.org，里面包含回溯信息（backtrace）。我觉得这是一个很好的折中方案。他们可以选择是否发送。而且我们通过获取回溯信息并将其塞进电子邮件，让他们变得非常简单，并且他们理解电子邮件是如何工作的。
There's no magic going on that they don't understand potentially reporting things that they can't see. And that worked really well to the extent that they don't understand, potentially reporting things that they can't see. And that worked really well to the extent that we couldn't keep up with all the crashes. And then with Brew, when it crashed, I just dumped as much information as I could that I would need to debug it in the terminal and then gave them the link to opening a new ticket.
没有任何他们可能不理解的魔法在发生，不会默默地报告他们看不到的东西。这非常成功，以至于我们应付不过来所有的崩溃。后来在 Brew 中，当它崩溃时，我只是在终端中转储了我调试它所需的所有尽可能多的信息，然后给他们一个打开新工单的链接。
I was like, if you want to report this bug, I'll fix it. Just copy and paste everything above into the ticket. Yeah, makes sense. And that was pretty effective. But part of the reason it was effective is that I was very quick to fix the bugs as well. With open source, a lot of the time, you report a bug and you never hear back.
我说，如果你想报告这个 bug，我会修复它。只需将上面的所有内容复制并粘贴到工单中即可。是的，说得通。这相当有效。但它有效的部分原因也是因为我修复 bug 的速度非常快。在开源领域，很多时候，你报告了一个 bug 却永远得不到回应。
If you've ever reported any tickets to other hear back if you look at your if you've ever reported like any tickets to other projects if you look at your github history you'll find tickets you've opened years ago that never even got a response like open source has a bad rep where you know like in general like we do it for free so you know most people don't really have the time to provide good support. With Homebrew, I quit my job to work on it full time so that I could give it that kind of support. Wow. Let's dive into that. And then that'll be a good segue into tea. So, yeah, kind of walk us through that.
如果你曾经向其他……得到回应。如果你看看你的……如果你曾经向其他项目提交过任何工单，如果你看看你的 GitHub 历史记录，你会发现你几年前开启的工单甚至从未得到过回复。开源有一个不好的名声，你知道的，总的来说，我们是免费做这件事的，所以大多数人其实没有时间提供良好的支持。在 Homebrew，我辞去了工作来全职从事它，这样我就可以提供那种支持。哇。让我们深入探讨一下这个。这将是过渡到 tea 的一个很好的切入点。所以，是的，请给我们讲讲这个过程。
I mean, you quit your job. Was there a ramp where you were already getting donations to a degree where you could quit did you kind of like just take a leap of faith like how did how did that work yeah i've never received a single donation no that's not true i've received some donations but only after i'd left the project okay so you how did you work full-time on it then i saved some money up um you can live fairly frugally in britain if you want to and i wanted to so i saved some money up and then started working at full-time like it had become apparent that it was a success and it was by far the most interesting thing i could think of to work on. And I wanted to make sure it was a big success. So yeah, I quit. And I survived about six months on what I had.
我的意思是，你辞去了工作。是不是有一个过渡期，当时你已经获得了足够程度的捐赠，所以你可以辞职？还是你有点像纵身一跃？这一切是怎么运作的？是的，我从来没有收到过单笔捐赠，不，这不是真的，我收到过一些捐赠，但那是在我离开项目之后。好吧，那你当时是怎么全职从事它的呢？我存了一些钱。呃，如果你愿意的话，在英国你可以过得相当节俭，而我当时就想这样，所以我存了一些钱，然后开始全职从事它。当时情况已经很明朗，它成功了，而且它绝对是我能想到的最有趣的工作。
I remember going to the bank and asking them what happens when you go overdraft, because I was about to go overdraft the next day. And they looked at me and I was like, you know, an idiot because I was 28 and I didn't understand how banks work. They told me it'd be fine. But, you know, I had to get another job. So I got another job at that point, worked for TweetDeck, made their mobile apps. But it began like this cycle for me where I would get jobs that I, you know, I wanted to do most of them.
我想确保它取得巨大成功。所以，是的，我辞职了。我靠着积蓄大约撑了六个月。
I don't like working on things I don't like. But, you know know my story is that I couldn't imagine working in chemistry for the rest of my life it made me extremely depressed so if I don't like the work then I get depressed so I have to like it to a certain extent but what I've wanted to do for the last 15 years pretty much is work on open source I find that it's just the place that I bring the most value to the world and I get the most satisfaction. I love working with these big communities and building tools that everybody needs, whatever kind of thing they're working on. It's just incredibly rewarding.
我记得去银行问他们透支时会发生什么，因为我第二天就要透支了。他们看着我，我觉得自己像个傻子，因为我当时 28 岁，却不明白银行是怎么运作的。他们告诉我没关系。但是，你知道，我不得不去找另一份工作。所以在那个时候我又找了一份工作，为 TweetDeck 工作，制作他们的移动端应用。但这对我来说开始形成了一个循环，我会去找那些——你知道的，大部分是我自己想做的工作。
And so I cycled for years between full-time work and working on Homebrew and my other open source projects. I've got quite a lot. None of them as big or as famous as homebrew of course uh until i burned out essentially like i it'd been years i've been doing two jobs essentially all the time and never really having enough time for the open source work and so i felt homebrew was good enough at that point, and so I left the project. People had turned up that were excellent. You really can get the best people in the world for open source,
我不喜欢做我不喜欢的事情。但是，你知道，我的故事是，我无法想象在余生中从事化学工作，那让我极度沮丧。所以如果我不喜欢这项工作，我就会抑郁，所以我必须在一定程度上喜欢它。不过在过去大约 15 年里，我真正想做的事情一直是从事开源工作。我发现这正是我为世界带来最大价值、获得最大满足感的地方。我喜欢与这些大型社区合作，构建每个人都需要工具，无论他们在从事什么类型的工作。这简直是太有回报了。
because they turn up, and they have to really want to do it. You're not paying them. They love it. Right, right. Yeah, that is amazing. I mean, I think you're right that it's a permanent mark on civilization.
所以在过去的几年里，我在全职工作、开发 Homebrew 以及我的其他开源项目之间循环。我有很多项目，当然没有一个像 Homebrew 那么大或那么有名，直到我基本上精疲力竭。多年来，我实际上一直同时做着两份工作，却从来没有足够的时间来进行开源工作，所以我觉得当时 Homebrew 已经足够成熟了，于是我离开了这个项目。不断有人涌现出来，他们都非常优秀。你真的能在开源领域招募到世界上最好的人才，
You could get a paycheck for that paycheck. I joke that I have direct deposit and direct withdrawal. The money comes in, the know, century, decades or centuries, way out of the future, and no one's using any of these things anymore. You know, those ideas will make their way into the derived projects. And, you know, the next person who builds a package manager is going to have a GitHub integration that's really lightweight like that. Right. And so in this way, those are the marks that are permanent. Yeah, well, brew. There's so many different brews now. The one I found the other day is called Pearl Brew. It did have a lot of influence, the ideas that it propagated.
因为他们自己会来，而且他们必须真心想做这件事。你没有付他们薪水。他们热爱它。对，对。是的，这太惊人了。我的意思是，我认为你是对的，这是对文明的一个永久印记。
And all the ideas I had for brew were based on other package managers I'd used. There were certainly some innovations in there where I'd put two of these ideas I had because of using other people's tooling together and made something that was better and newer. But yeah, we were all building on the shoulders of giants in open source, and it's part of the reason it's so great. That's why we hate the idea of software patents, right? All open source people hate that because the very idea that you
你可以为那份薪水拿到工资。我开玩笑说我有直接存款和直接取款。钱进来了，你知道，几个世纪以后，再也没有人使用这些东西了。你知道，这些想法会融入到派生项目中。而且，下一个构建包管理器的人将拥有一个非常轻量级的 GitHub 集成，就像那样。没错。所以通过这种方式，这些才是永久的印记。是的，好吧，brew。现在有太多不同的 brew 了。我前几天发现的一个叫 Pearl Brew。它确实有很多影响，它传播了这些想法。
couldn't take some good idea someone else has had and use it to make something better or new or different is very offensive but you know that's the world yeah you know that was a big deal like uh around 10 years ago and then i haven't heard very much about patents or patent trolling in a while. So I don't really know what happened there. It'd be fascinating to dive into that. We should do a whole show on just patents and what really happened there. It seems like we're in some type of healthy situation now. I don't know if it's like a hostage situation or what's going on, but it seems like the patent trolls have died down lately at least yeah i think you're right and i hadn't really noticed that so that is is a huge relief there was certainly a period where it was starting to look like these software patterns and
我对 brew 的所有想法都基于我用过的其他包管理器。里面肯定有一些创新，因为我把从别人工具那里学到的两个想法结合起来，做出了更好更新的东西。但是，是的，我们在开源中都是站在巨人的肩膀上，这也是它如此伟大的原因之一。这就是为什么我们讨厌软件专利的概念，对吧？所有开源的人都讨厌它，因为那种
the trolls that owned them were going to seriously disrupt and damage software and the internet yeah so something happened yeah Yeah, totally. Maybe it was the Free Software Foundation. Maybe they pulled it off, what they were trying to do. Yeah, I think. I mean, the last I'd heard about it was, you know, these big companies, these FANG companies, were all stocking up on these patents.
你不能拿别人的一些好创意并用它来做更好、更新或不同的东西的想法，是非常令人反感的。但你知道，这就是现实世界。是的，你知道，那是大约 10 年前的一件大事，然后我有一段时间没有听到太多关于专利或专利流氓的事情了。所以我真的不知道后来发生了什么。深入研究这个一定很着迷。我们应该专门做一整期节目来讨论专利以及那里真正发生了什么。看起来我们现在处于某种健康的状态。我不知道这是否像人质事件或其他什么情况，但至少最近专利流氓似乎已经平息了。是的，我想你是对的，我之前并没有真正注意到这一点，所以这是一个巨大的解脱。曾经确实有一段时间，这些软件专利和
And so I think it created almost like this mutually assured destruction type scenario. And maybe that got everybody to calm down. Yeah. Yeah. So, okay, let's jump into tea. So tea is, you've said so far, tea is a package manager. So kind of tell us about like what got you inspired to do tea?
拥有它们的流氓看起来将严重扰乱和损害软件和互联网。是的，所以发生了某些事情。是的，完全是这样。也许是自由软件基金会。也许他们成功做到了他们一直试图做的事。是的，我懂。我的意思是，我听到的最后关于它的消息是，这些大公司，这些 FANNG 公司，都在囤积这些专利。
Was it straight from homebrew to tea or was there anything in the middle? And kind of what, you know, lead us into like what tea is all about and what you're trying to do tea was it straight from homebrew to tea or was there anything in the middle and kind of what you know lead us into like what tea is is all about and what you're trying to do there yeah so well i stopped working on homebrew like 2015 2016 and i'd been like winding down for about a year or so before that really uh i'd become very interested in iPhone apps, which I stopped being interested in a few years ago. So in between, I did a lot of iPhone work and made a lot of open source for the iPhone ecosystem as a result. But I never thought I would do another brew. My people have asked me all the time since, are you ever going to do another one and like i certainly been keeping notes over the years about what i would do if i made something like a brute two like i'm
所以我认为这几乎创造了一种类似相互保证毁灭的场景。也许这让每个人都冷静下来了。是的。好吧，让我们来谈谈 tea。所以 tea 是，你到目前为止所说的，tea 是一个包管理器。那么给我们讲讲是什么激发了你做 tea 的灵感？
a possessive note taker in many ways and i had pages and pages of it which i've put into t but i didn't think i would like i don't typically go back and do sequels. I like new projects and new ideas, but it's been long enough. And, well, I have a son now. Oh, congrats. Just, thank you. It's four months. He's quite a little rascal.
它是直接从 Homebrew 过渡到 tea，还是中间还有别的什么？以及是什么引导我们了解 tea 的全貌以及你想要做的事情？它是直接从 Homebrew 过渡到 tea，还是中间还有别的什么？以及是什么引导我们了解 tea 的全貌以及你想要做的事情？是的，所以我……好吧，我停止开发 Homebrew 大约是在 2015、2016 年，在那之前大约一年左右我一直在逐渐淡出。其实，我曾对 iPhone 应用非常感兴趣，不过几年前我对它们的兴趣也消退了。所以在中间那段时间里，我做了很多 iPhone 的开发，并因此为 iPhone 生态系统制作了大量的开源软件。但我从没想过我会再做一个 brew。自那以后人们一直问我，你还会再做一次吗？而且我肯定这些年一直在做笔记，如果我制作类似 brew 2 的东西我会怎么做。我
About a year ago, me and my girlfriend were trying to get pregnant and at the time i was working on uh open source and some other little projects i was trying to make some like micro sasses and stuff like that i wanted to work for myself and i wanted to be able to work on open source when i wanted to be able to work on open source so we got pregnant a lot quicker than expected so uh it the gynecologist suggested it would take a year but it took about two weeks and uh suddenly i found that i all my plans were in a bit of disarray so i was like okay i've either got to go back into industry you know get a normal job so i can like provide for a family or I got to figure something out. So I pulled over all my old ideas and came across Brew2, the ideas I'd written down
在很多方面是个喜欢收集笔记的人，我有很多很多页的笔记，我都把它们放进了 tea 里。但我原以为我不会——我通常不回过头去制作续集。我喜欢新的项目和新的想法，但时间已经过去够久了。而且，嗯，我现在有了一个儿子。哦，恭喜。谢谢。他四个月大了。他是个十足的小淘气。
there. And I had a friend who's been trying to get me into crypto and Web3 for years. So he got into it like, you know, very early. I never found it very interesting because it seemed like it was just about money, you know very early but i never found it very interesting uh because it seemed like it was just about money you know right and i thought you know i thought bitcoin was very interesting and innovative and quite astonishing in some ways like that white paper's worth reading um but it still just seemed like money but he'd been trying to get me into that and i was like okay well maybe there's something there so i was also reading up on web3 and seeing what it was like whoever called it web3 that was a great idea
大约一年前，我和女友正试图怀孕，当时我正在从事开源工作和其他一些小项目，我试图做一些微型 SaaS 之类的事情。我想为自己工作，我希望能够在我想做开源的时候就能做开源。所以我们怀孕的速度比预期的要快得多，妇科医生曾建议这需要一年时间，但大约两周就成了。突然间，我发现我所有的计划都有些被打乱了，所以我想，好吧，要么我得重回行业，找一份正常的工作来养家糊口，要么我得想出点办法。所以我翻出了我所有的旧想法，发现了 Brew2，也就是我当时写下的那些想法。
incidentally like whether or not it will earn the title is yet to be seen but it made it sound different and interesting and so that got me into it and it was while i was late night exploring my backlog of ideas and playing around with openSea and NFTs and digital contracts, that I suddenly realized that there was a possibility there to combine Brew with Web3 and, in effect, provide a mechanism for funding open source. So people like myself could live off open source rather than either turn into a passion project where you're begging for donations or seeking bounties or make it useful to Microsoft so they'll hire you. You can keep your project for yourself, make some money with it. So essentially, I then found out my friend and he thought it was a genius idea.
我有一个朋友，多年来一直试图带我进入加密货币和 Web3 领域。所以他很早就进入了这个领域。我从来没觉得它多有意思，因为看起来它只跟钱有关。很早就涉足其中，但我一直觉得它没太大意思，因为它看起来好像只跟钱有关，对吧？而且我想，我觉得比特币非常有趣、极具创新性，在某些方面相当令人震惊，那篇白皮书确实值得一读，但它看起来依然只是钱。不过他一直在试图把我拉进那个圈子，我就想，好吧，也许里面有些名堂。所以我当时也在恶补 Web3 的相关知识，看看它究竟是怎么回事。不管是谁想出了“Web3”这个名字，这真是一个绝妙的主意。
And we managed to get at this point where, we're $18 million of funding. I started active development on it in April. And we genuinely believe we can change how open source is funded. So let's walk through that. So you have a friend who's really into crypto. And the two of you kind of click with this idea which i think is a phenomenal idea basically you have this new kind of uh uh let's say more liquid more electronic way of transferring money you have a marketplace where you have um one thing just segue one thing you'll
顺便说一句，它能否真正当得起这个称号还有待观察，但它听起来确实与众不同且引人入胜。这让我入了坑。正是在我深夜探索我的想法积压、摆弄 OpenSea、NFT 和数字合约的时候，我突然意识到，这里存在着将 Brew 与 Web3 结合起来的可能性，从而实际上为开源提供了一种资助机制。这样一来，像我这样的人就可以靠开源生活，而不是把项目变成一个苦苦哀求捐赠、寻求赏金的激情项目，或者为了让微软觉得有用而受雇于他们。你可以为自己保留项目，并用它赚点钱。基本上，我随后找到了我的朋友，他也觉得这是一个天才的想法。
know now that you have a kid it's going to take a few years. When your kid starts preschool, you'll be sick pretty much all of September. But you have this marketplace where on one side you have, you know, people who are using open source software and are getting value from it. And on the other side, you have the people producing it. And so it seems like you can create, you know, a very efficient market there. How did that turn into a funded company? So like, who did you speak to? Like, what's that chain of events like?
我们设法走到了这一步，我们获得了 1800 万美元的资金。我在 4 月份开始对其实施积极开发。我们真心相信我们可以改变开源的资助方式。让我们来捋一捋。所以你有一个对加密货币非常热衷的朋友。你们两个对这个想法一拍即合，我认为这是一个极其绝佳的想法：基本上你拥有这种新型的、可以说是更具流动性、更电子化的资金转移方式。你拥有一个市场，里面有……顺便插一句，你现在有了孩子就会懂，这需要几年的时间。当你的孩子开始上幼儿园时，你基本上整个九月都会生病。但在这个市场里，一方面是那些使用开源软件并从中获得价值的人，另一方面是创造这些软件的人。所以看起来你可以在那里创造一个非常高效的市场。这怎么就变成了一家获得资助的公司呢？比如，你都跟谁聊过？整个事件的发展脉络是怎样的？
Because, you know, a lot of people know absolutely nothing about, even people who have been in the industry, I even put myself in this position, know nothing about startups. We've heard the word seed round. We don't know really what it means. And so kind of walk us through what that journey was like till now. It's a good question. And it's fun stories, really. So, well, I'm very fortunate because when you have something that's as well known as Homebrew, it makes things a lot simpler.
因为，你知道，很多人对此一无所知，甚至连业内人士——我甚至把自己也归入这一类——对初创公司也一无所知。我们听过“种子轮”这个词，但并不真正理解它意味着什么。所以给我们讲讲，从那时到现在这段旅程是怎样的。这是一个好问题。而且这确实是一个有趣的故事。嗯，我很幸运，因为当你拥有像 Homebrew 这样知名度极高的项目时，事情会变得简单得多。
You know, we estimate that Homebrew has 40 million users and it's probably true because they're not all developers they're also all these other professions that need the tooling that comes with homebrew right initially it's going to be very focused on developers but over time it can evolve i've built t to be the ultimate packaging tool, but we can talk about its future set in a minute. So, yeah, like, so my friend has known me for years and he's wanted to work with me on something this big before. We've worked on minor startups and done contracting together and things. Timothy Lewis. So he, because he's been in crypto so long,
据我们估计，Homebrew 拥有 4000 万用户，这很可能是真的，因为他们不仅仅是开发人员，还包括所有需要 Homebrew 附带工具的其他职业。最初，它将非常专注于开发者，但随着时间的推移，它可以不断演进。我把 tea 构建成了终极的打包工具，但我们稍后可以讨论它的未来功能集。所以，是的，我的朋友认识我多年，他之前一直想和我一起合作这么大的项目。我们以前合作过一些小型初创公司，一起接包干活之类的。Timothy Lewis。所以，由于他涉足加密货币领域很长时间了，
just knew a lot of people that were willing to invest in the sector i remember the first meeting we had with one of our first investors i was talking it through and he was fascinated by my story and i said how you know the only things i'd ever got from homebrew were google once sent me a blanket and things like this like great pitch stories because it's true they sent me a blanket and they said thanks for homebrew wow i didn't know your address oh it's google right i mean they didn't ask me for my address you know they've had you've had like give back to open source programs for years and this is one of the first and all it was that year was a blanket like now they actually throw money at it but yeah at the time i got a uh similarly i got a google home
他认识许多愿意在这个领域投资的人。我记得我们跟其中一位早期投资者的第一次会面，我正在讲述这些，他对我的故事很着迷，我提到我从 Homebrew 那里得到的唯一东西就是有一次 Google 送了我一条毯子之类的事。这真是一个极好的推介故事，因为这是真的，他们确实送了我一条毯子，并说“谢谢你开发了 Homebrew”。哇，我不知道你的地址。哦，那是 Google，对吧？我的意思是，他们并没有向我要地址。你知道的，他们多年来一直有回馈开源的项目，这是最早的其中之一，而那一年送的仅仅是一条毯子。现在他们是真的往里面砸钱了。但当时我得到了一台……类似地，我得到了一台 Google Home。
it's actually in the kids' playroom right behind me, behind this wall. Yeah, I don't remember exactly how it worked, but yeah, I remember giving them my address and then being a little skeptical, but yeah, a random Google Home just showed up at my house a week later. Yeah, that's nice. But still, certainly not enough to pay the bills if you're going to do open source full time but yeah so I was pitching and then this guy was like okay I'm going to just
它实际上就在我身后的儿童游戏室里，就在这堵墙后面。是的，我不记得具体是怎么运作的，但没错，我记得把地址给了他们，当时还有点半信半疑，不过一周后，一个随机的 Google Home 就这样寄到了我家。是的，这挺好的。但即便如此，如果你打算全职从事开源，这显然不足以支付账单。不过是的，当时我在进行推介，然后这个人就说：“好吧，我要邀请我的朋友来跟你谈谈。”那个人是个开发者，然后他来了，我的联合创始人就问：“你知道 Homebrew 吗？”那人说：“哦，那个 Mac 上的包管理器？”他回答：“对。”“你用它吗？”那人说，
invite my friend down to talk to you and the guy was like a developer and so the guy turns up and my co-founder goes so do you know Homebrew and he was like what the package manager for Mac and he's like yeah do you use it and he was like, what? The package manager for Mac? And he's like, yeah. He said, do you use it? And he was like, oh, God, we use it all the time.
“什么？Mac 上的包管理器？”他回答：“对。”对方说：“你用吗？”那人说：“天哪，我们一直在用。”
So, you know, the first key moment in us, like, starting to build this raise, and I'd had, like, this enormous piece of validation from just, like, some guy who'd been invited to, like, vet me, essentially. So it does definitely help if you have something as big as homebrew behind you that's really cool actually one one really quick homebrew story and then i want to get back to tea but i um i actually think maybe not solely maybe solely responsible for keeping homebrew alive at facebook which is now Meta. There was a whole enterprise engineering team that wanted to kill Homebrew.
所以，你知道我们开始进行这轮融资的第一个关键时刻，我从一个被邀请来实质上对进行我进行审查的普通人那里，获得了巨大无比的认可。所以，如果你的背后有像 Homebrew 这样庞大的项目支撑，那绝对是很有帮助的。这其实真的很酷。顺便讲一个非常简短的 Homebrew 故事，然后我想回到 tea 上来。不过我……我其实觉得——也许不完全是，但可能负有全部责任——正是 Homebrew 使得它得以在 Facebook（现为 Meta）存活下来。当时有一个整个企业工程团队想要杀死 Homebrew。
And they actually, we were in this arms race where Homebrew installs things to user local. So they were locking down user local to where when you ran brew commands, it would fail in really odd ways. And then somebody, I think it was a colleague of mine, maybe I did, we submitted something to Homebrewer when it couldn't read user local. It told you that like right off the bat.
事实上，我们当时处在这样一种军备竞赛中：Homebrew 会将东西安装到 usr/local。所以他们将 usr/local 锁死，导致你运行 brew 命令时会以非常奇怪的方式失败。然后有人——我想是我的一位同事，也许是我——我们向 Homebrew 提交了一些代码，当它无法读取 usr/local 时，它会立刻告诉你这一点。
So then people started writing scripts where it was like chmod user local, then run Homebrew. And then an hour later, you know, Puppet would kick in and like change it back and you'd be in this arms race and uh um and and the alternative to all of the points you mentioned earlier the alternative was not developer friendly it was painful and um it was basically like the it was a internal version of the app store so you would go to like the equivalent of like the apple app store and you would search for like you know lib open ssl and then you'd have to click the button to install it and it's like just ridiculous um and so there's yeah there's this big uh battle back and forth we finally won and so i think there's still a ton of people uh using using homebrew it's just a
于是人们开始编写脚本，内容类似于先 chmod usr/local，然后运行 Homebrew。一个小时后，你知道的，Puppet 就会介入并将其改回去，然后你就陷入了这种军备竞赛中。而且……而且你之前提到的所有痛点的替代方案对开发者并不友好，那是相当痛苦的。基本上就像是……那是应用商店的内部版本，所以你要去到类似于苹果应用商店的地方，然后搜索类似于 libssl 之类的东西，接着你得点击按钮来安装它，这简直是太荒谬了。
testament how good the experience is that's a great story i love it i haven't really heard one like it before because you know i know that these big companies use it uh probably still because i obviously my famous failed google interview i was like you won't use it and you won't hire me um wait wait hang on i don't you have to you have to you have to explain that one. What happened? So it was like 2015, and I was looking for new work. So my wife at the time said, why don't you reply to Google's emails for a change? Because they've been trying to recruit me since Homebrew got big. So I didn't know what I was going to do.
所以，是的，这里经历了一场重大的来回拉锯战，我们最终赢了。所以我想仍然有大量的人在使用 Homebrew。这证明了它的体验有多棒。这真是一个好故事，我很喜欢。我以前真的没听过类似的经历，因为我知道这些大公司在使用它，大概现在还在用，因为显然我那次著名的 Google 面试失败时，我就说过：“你们会用它的，但你们不会雇我。”等等，等等，等一下。你得解释一下那个。发生了什么？那是 2015 年左右，我在找新工作。我当时的妻子就说：“你为什么不回一下 Google 的邮件呢？就当换个口味。”因为自从 Homebrew 火了之后，他们就一直试图招募我。所以我当时不知道自己该做什么。
I didn't really want to work for somewhere like Google, but I thought, why thought why not i'll just do the interview so the recruiter phones me and said well we're skipping over the phone interview because of your uh you know prestige i was like well okay but i don't have a computer science degree right because obviously i knew that google interviews were always like computer science-y. And the recruiter said, oh yeah, we know, that's fine. We'll have custom interviews for you. I was like, well, okay, excellent. Then the first interview when I got there was asking me to invert a binary tree, which obviously I didn't know how to do. So it wasn't a good day. I had some interviews that were better than others, but I figured I didn't get it. And then a week later they phoned me to say that I didn't get it. And then I
我其实不想去 Google这样的大地方工作，但我想，为什么不呢？我就去面试一下呗。于是招聘人员打电话给我说：“鉴于你的声望，我们决定跳过电话面试。”我说：“好吧，但我没有计算机科学学位啊。”因为很显然我知道 Google 的面试一向都很偏向计算机科学。招聘人员说：“哦，是的，我们知道，没关系。我们会为你安排定制面试。”我说：“好吧，太棒了。”然后我到那儿之后的第一场面试，居然要求我反转一个二叉树，这我显然不会。所以那并不是美好的一天。有些面试比其他的要好一些，但我猜我没被录用。一周后他们打电话告诉我没被录用。然后我
immediately went to Twitter and typed 90% of our engineers use the software you wrote, homebrew in brackets, but you can't invert a binary tree on a blackboard so F off. And at the time I had like 600 followers, so I didn't
立刻打开 Twitter，打下这样一段话：“我们 90% 的工程师都在使用你编写的软件（括号里写了 Homebrew），但你在黑板上却反转不了一个二叉树，所以滚蛋吧。”当时我有大约 600 个粉丝，所以我并不
think it would matter. By the end of the next week, I had 15,000 followers. Oh my gosh. That's amazing. This tweet had been on Hacker News like eight times. Supposedly, it caused Google to look at their interview process and make changes. I have friends who were at Google at the time. They said there was a big fuss, a big stink made.
觉得这会有什么影响。到了第二周结束时，我有 15,000 个粉丝。哦，天哪。太惊人了。这条推文在 Hacker News 上出现了大约八次。据说，这促使 Google 审视了他们的面试流程并作出了改变。我有当时在 Google 的朋友，他们说当时引起了很大的轰动和风波。
But it also led to me getting like 200 job offers from other companies. That's awesome. It was a pretty remarkable week. I felt bad because, as I say, I had very few followers. I didn't think it would be like a viral tweet
但这也让我收到了来自其他公司的多达 200 个工作机会。太棒了。那真是相当了不起的一周。我当时感觉很糟糕，正如我所说，我当时粉丝很少。我没想到它会变成一条病毒式传播的推文，
where this place had like 4 million views or something. It still gets replies. It's like it happened yesterday. 2015 happened yesterday 2015 people seven years ago what you should do is you should you should sort the offers based off like your own personal priority and then you know put them into a binary tree and invert it yeah well after that i did go home and figure out how to do it because jonathan blow you know jonathan blow oh the developer braid right yeah yeah exactly like yeah he i've always admired the guy and then suddenly he's in my twitter thread telling me that i'm a bad developer because i can't do this and i hurt my feelings honestly the guy was a bit of a hero of mine and like he said i watched his documentary and i loved
浏览量达到了 400 万左右之类的地方。现在它下面还会收到回复。就好像那是昨天发生的一样。2015 年就像是昨天发生的。2015 年已经是七年前了。你当时该做的是，你应该根据你自己的个人优先级对这些 offer 进行排序，然后……你知道的，把它们放进一个二叉树里并把它反转。好吧，在那之后我确实回家去弄懂了怎么做，因为乔纳森·布洛（Jonathan Blow）——你知道乔纳森·布洛吗？哦，那个游戏开发者，对吧？对，对，就是他。我一直很崇拜这家伙，结果突然间他在我的 Twitter 评论区里告诉我，我不是个好开发者，因为我不会做这个，这伤了我的自尊心说实话。这家伙曾算是我的偶像之一，而且我说过，我看过他的纪录片，我也很喜欢他的游戏，而他却说：“其实你可能不是个好开发者，马克，你或许该去学学怎么做。”不，我后来去学了，谢谢你，乔纳森。好吧，你能坦然接受这一点是好事。有些人会被你谈到的很多事情彻底击垮，比如不得不改变学科，被自己的偶像当面痛击，但你却把所有这些机遇都化为了前进的阶梯，对吧？嗯，我很感激。我想我一直都是这种性格的人。
his games and he's like you're probably not a good developer actually max you should probably go and learn how to do that no i went and learned it thanks jonathan well it's good that you took it on the chin and you know some people would have been crushed by a lot of the things you talked about i mean having to change disciplines you disciplines, getting your hero kind of taking a sucker punch at you, but you kind of took all of these opportunities to step forward, you know? Well, I appreciate that. I guess it's always been the kind of person I am.
总是试图推动事情向前发展。所以，是的，我接受了苹果的工作。苹果向我提供了工作，我干了一年。我是对的，我不适合在大公司工作，流程太多了。我也发现了这一点。我的意思是，我在大公司工作了，我不知道，15 年左右吧。但现在我在一家小公司，感觉好太多了。
Always trying to move forward with things. So yeah, I took the job at Apple. Apple offered me work and I lasted a year. I was right. I don't work well at big companies, too much process. I also found this out. I mean, I worked for big companies for, I don't know, 15 years or something. But now that I'm at a smaller company, it's so much better.
它实在太契合我的个性了。好吧，那么对于一个打造了最受欢迎的包管理器之一的人来说，你获得了一些资金，所以你有……你刚才说目前有 13 个人？我觉得更像是还有别人，而且人数一直在变动。我目前对那部分稍微当甩手掌柜，尽管我是 CEO，因为我正在积极开发产品。你知道，在这一点上我是核心开发者。我们正在招聘更多人，这样我就不用再当核心开发者了。不过，老实说，
It just fits my personality so much better. Okay, so based off someone who's made you know one of the most popular package managers you know you secured some funding and so you have uh you said 13 people right now i think it's more just like someone else and people keep dying i'm a little hands off with that side of things at the moment, even though I'm the CEO, because I'm actively building the product. You know, I'm the key developer at this point. We're hiring more so I can stop being the key developer. But, you know, the truth is,
我对自己正在构建的东西了如指掌。我已经思考它好几年了。所以我正在收尾。我们希望能在今年较早的时候推出它。本质上，它就像是一个包管理器，但被赋予了超强功能。这是不是与操作系统无关的？你都在管理什么类型的包？
I know the thing we're building, like, very thoroughly. I've been thinking about it for years. So I'm finishing that off. We're hoping to launch it soon-ish this year. Essentially, it's like a package manager, but overpowered. And is this like OS agnostic? Like what kind of packages are you managing?
所以在这个阶段，它和 Brew 管理的类型差不多，以及像 Debian 的 Apt、Yum 以及所有 Linux 的包管理器那样的包。也就是栈的那基础部分。但因为我们产品供应的一部分将是这个区块链组件，那是我们存储包数据的地方。而且我们不存储它，是由你们来存储。
So at this point, it's the same sort of stuff that Brew manages and packages like Debian's, Apt, and Yum, and all the Linux ones. So that base part of the stack. But because part of our product offering is going to be this blockchain component, that's where we're storing the package data. And we're not storing it, you're storing it.
作为开源维护者，你将使用私钥发布到我们的链上，本质上是一个代表你的开源发布和依赖信息的 NFT。所以我们最终正在构建一个与平台无关的通用包注册表。我希望所有开源包都能有一个单一的数据源。现在的重复实在太严重了。
As open source maintainers, you will publish using a private key into our chain, essentially an NFT that represents releases for your open source and dependency information. So we're building essentially an agnostic package registry for once and for all. I want there to be one source of data for all open source packages. It's awfully duplicated.
作为开源维护者，你将使用私钥发布到我们的链上，本质上是一个代表你的开源发布和依赖信息的NFT。因此，我们本质上是在构建一个通用的包注册表，一劳永逸。我希望所有开源包都能有一个统一的数据源。目前的重复实在是太严重了。
Even with brew, I made it worse by doing yet another one. Although, you know, I get why. But this time, essentially, we're making the database. But because this graph understands the entire open source ecosystem and how it depends on each other,
即便有了 Homebrew，我又做了一个更糟糕的决定，那就是再搞一个。不过，你知道的，我理解为什么。但这一次，本质上我们在构建数据库。不过由于这个图谱理解了整个开源生态系统以及它们之间的依赖关系，
when you put some token into that graph, it can distribute it automatically using digital contracts to the rest of the graph. So if React, for example, is given some token, then all of React's dependencies, the node portion and the portion under node that is the part that we're starting with, that T is going to package,
当你把一些代币放入该图谱时，它可以通过数字合约自动将代币分发给图谱中的其余部分。因此，举例来说，如果 React 获得了一些代币，那么 React 的所有依赖项（即 Node 部分以及我们从这部分开始的、T 将要打包的那部分 Node 下面的部分），
can be given a percentage decreasing all the way down to libc, essentially. This is the golden principle of it and why it's going to work we're not changing how open source works as well like you're not going to have to like pay to use t and t is just going to be one client of this blockchain component so we're using like the steeping system effectively so we're doing like what banks do with interest effectively but you invest some money with the bank and the bank gives you an interest payment as a reward. A blockchain will, using proof of stake, give these rewards to the open source ecosystem. So you'll get a little bit of that reward as thanks for securing this network.
基本上可以获得一个逐层递减、一直延伸到 libc 的百分比。这是它的核心原则，也是它能奏效的原因。我们并没有改变开源的工作方式，比如你不需要付费才能使用 t，t 只是这个区块链组件的一个客户端。所以我们实际上是在使用类似质押的系统，我们基本上在做银行对利息所做的事情——你把一些钱存入银行，银行作为回报给你支付利息。区块链将通过权益证明（Proof of Stake），将这些奖励给予开源生态系统。因此，作为感谢你保护这个网络的回报，你将获得一小部分奖励。
So we're expecting developers and companies, especially companies, I think like these fan companies that don't want to use Homebrew but are forced to, like Facebook, should be basically investing tens of millions of dollars a year into the open source that they use. And because we are building a set of tooling around that to assist that, essentially we're automating the part of the process for these companies or individuals or projects or groups on figuring out what open source they use and allowing them to put money into that system. Well, right now, you know, Google have to email you and say, hey, we want to send you a Google Home. Like, how do we do it? And then, you know, there's a limit to how many projects they can support in that manner because it's so manual
所以我们期待开发者和公司，尤其是公司——我认为像那些不想用 Homebrew 但又被迫使用的科技巨头公司，比如 Facebook，基本上应该每年向他们所使用的开源项目投资数千万美元。由于我们正在围绕这一点构建一套工具来协助完成这项工作，本质上我们是在为这些公司、个人、项目或群组自动化部分流程，帮他们弄清楚自己使用了哪些开源项目，并允许他们将资金投入该系统。好吧，目前，你知道的，谷歌不得不发电子邮件对你说，嘿，我们想送你一个 Google Home。听着，我们该怎么做？然后，你知道的，他们能以这种方式支持的项目数量是有限制的，因为这太手工化了。
effectively we're automating that so i'm incredibly excited about what we're doing on the blockchain side also i came into this knowing that there's no way our blockchain component would get much usage unless there was a kick-ass set of tools that go with it that encourage that adoption and that usage so t is also like a successor to brew in many ways a general tool for developers that incorporates a lot of ideas i've had over the years because i feel like the package manager can be so much more than just a package manager like It controls and allows you power over every tool in your development stack. It's just so much more that can be done
实际上我们正在将其自动化，所以我对我们在区块链方面所做的事情感到非常兴奋。同时，我进入这个领域时就知道，除非有一套非常棒的、能够鼓励这种采用和使用的配套工具，否则我们的区块链组件是不可能得到广泛使用的。因此，在许多方面，t 也是 brew 的继承者，是一个面向开发者的通用工具，它融合了我这些年来的许多想法。因为我觉得包管理器可以做的远不止是一个包管理器——它控制并赋予你对开发栈中每个工具的掌控权。除了安装更新和管理你所使用的一系列软件包之外，还有更多的事情可以做，
than just installing updates and managing a set of packages that you use. So when we launch, it's going to have a few cool features. Essentially, we've made the Package Manager into a virtual environment manager for everything. You install a set of packages and set versions that are defined, and you can carrot update them, just like we were talking about with Node.
当我们推出时，它将具备一些很酷的功能。本质上，我们将包管理器变成了一个适用于一切的虚拟环境管理器。你安装了一组定义好的软件包和版本，并且你可以像我们之前讨论 Node 时那样，用波浪号（caret）来更新它们。
So you say, I depend on version 2.2 plus up to version 3 of this tool. And then You can have independent projects that you're working on that use completely independent sets of tooling. Even things like Postgres we can instantiate versions of Postgres, multiple versions on your system at once. They're all using
所以你会说，我依赖于这个工具的 2.2 版本一直到 3 版本。然后，你可以拥有你正在独立开发的、使用完全独立的工具集的项目。甚至像 Postgres 这样的东西，我们也可以在你的系统上同时实例化多个版本的 Postgres。它们都在使用
isolated, containerized things. Effectively, I'm making it so you don't want to use Docker for development. It sounds similar to Snap. Snap on Linux has some of these ideas in it. Yeah, there is stuff that can do this, like Nix. It's a big one where it makes, effectively, environments to work in. But I'm coming at it from the perspective of the developer
隔离的、容器化的东西。实际上，我让大家在开发时不再想去使用 Docker。这听起来有点像 Snap。Linux 上的 Snap 就包含其中一些理念。是的，确实有一些工具可以做到这一点，比如 Nix。这是一个很大的工具，它实际上可以创建用于工作的环境。但我是从开发者的角度出发的，
and not a system engineer or a DevOps person. This is a developer tool where i'm making it extremely pleasant for developers to use you probably want to this sounds awesome so as far as uh you know we have a lot of folks who are they're just graduating or they're um you know looking for internships you know what's the state of hiring right now at T? Are you looking for either of those, both of them? Oh, yeah, actively. I need another five or six developers before the end of the year. And then almost certainly we just keep scaling up.
而不是从系统工程师或 DevOps 人员的角度。这是一个开发者工具，我让开发者用起来感到极其愉快。你大概会想……这听起来太棒了。那么，据我所知，我们有很多刚刚毕业的朋友，或者是正在寻找实习机会的朋友，目前 T 的招聘情况是怎样的？你在寻找这两者之一，还是两者都要？哦，是的，非常积极。在今年年底之前我还需要另外五六个开发者。然后几乎可以肯定的是，我们会继续扩大规模。
Internships are a little trickier because a lot of the work we're doing is packaging. And the truth is, they don't teach you that at school. They don't really teach it anywhere. We're having trouble hiring as a result. We're looking at all the existing package managers essentially right now i really need a windows packager because we are a cross-platform tool i believe as a developer especially nowadays you should be able to work on whatever platform you want and if you're part of a team that team should not like say okay you have to use a mac because that's always really support it should be uh okay you just use t and t will
实习稍微麻烦一点，因为我们所做的大部分工作都是打包。事实是，学校里不教这个。任何地方其实都不教。因此我们在招聘时遇到了困难。我们目前基本上在关注所有现成的包管理器，我真的很需要一个 Windows 打包人员，因为我们是一个跨平台工具。我认为作为一个开发者，特别是现在，你应该能够在任何你想用的平台上工作。如果你属于一个团队，那个团队不应该说“好吧，你必须用 Mac，因为那是唯一真正受支持的”。它应该是“好吧，你只需使用 t，t 会
make sure that the system that you're building with is the same for all of us even though the platform underneath is different uh so we're supporting linux and mac very well at the moment and windows so so we need a windows package but i'm generally hiring full stack uh i want some react devs i want javascript devs. I want JavaScript devs. A big part of what we're doing is we think that something like T is really an app store. And so we're going to have an app. Like, you know, package managers have had apps before, but ours will be much nicer. And also integrated heavily into the web.
确保你构建时所用的系统对我们所有人来说都是一样的，尽管底层平台不同”。所以我们目前对 Linux、Mac 以及 Windows 的支持都很好。我们需要一个 Windows 打包人员，但我通常在招全栈开发——我想要一些 React 开发者，我想要 JavaScript 开发者。我想要 JavaScript 开发者。我们正在做的事情很大一部分在于，我们认为像 T 这样的东西实际上是一个应用商店。因此我们将拥有一个应用。就像，你知道的，包管理器以前也有过应用，但我们的会好得多。而且它还深度集成到网络中。
So I want one-click installs from the web, essentially. Install nodes straight from the web, one click. Yeah, I felt like that's one thing that Linux got really nicely, is you can download a dev file, and it opens a deep link in the software manager, and you just click install, and you're done. Yeah, some of these conveniences, we're just bringing them all together essentially there's a suite of other like surprise features i think you're just going to open up entirely new ways of i know it sounds pretentious
所以基本上我想要网页端一键安装。直接从网页端安装 Node，一键搞定。是的，我觉得这是 Linux 做得很好的地方之一，你可以下载一个 deb 文件，它会在软件管理器中打开一个深层链接（deep link），你只需点击安装就完成了。是的，其中一些便利之处，我们正把它们全部整合在一起。本质上，还有一套其他令人惊奇的功能，我觉得它们将为我们打开全新的方式……我知道这听起来很自命不凡，
but like effectively i'm just trying to like break down barriers for developers i want developers to spend all their time making awesome stuff and none of their time zero uh worrying about how to install things and how to get started with things or experimenting with new tools or the amount of new stuff that comes out every week i want you to be able to feel that you can try out like at least half of it because there's a very simple way by the t website to like boot up effectively a sandbox and try out like a suggestion on like how to use that thing effectively a playground for those tools yeah super cool yeah i do feel like the the economic uh model is is also something I really appreciate. I have a, for Eternal Terminal, I have a GitHub donations button, which I put very little effort into promoting or anything like that.
但实际上我只是想为开发者打破障碍。我希望开发者把所有时间都花在制作棒极了的东西上，而把零时间花在担心如何安装东西、如何开始使用东西、或者试验新工具上，以及每周涌现的大量新事物上。我希望你能觉得你可以尝试其中至少一半的新东西，因为通过 t 网站有一个非常简单的方法来启动一个沙盒，并试用关于如何有效使用该东西的建议——基本上就是这些工具的游乐场。是的，超级酷。是的，我确实觉得这种经济模型也是我非常赞赏的一点。对于 Eternal Terminal，我有一个 GitHub 捐赠按钮，但我花在推广它上面的精力非常少。
And I think there is one donor. So if you're listening to this show, thank you so much, whoever you are. But I mean, this is also part of the problem is I have no way of really, at least I don't think I have any way of reaching out to that person and saying, hey, what do you like about this? I mean, you're willing to put money behind it. So, so, you know, your opinion really matters, right? So that dialogue isn't there. And the friction is just really high. So I think that you're attempting to address some of those things. Well, if you talk to your average developer, they feel bad that they don't support open source in some manner. But the truth is, it's very difficult to know how to support 10,000 packages that you use on a day-to-day basis. So indeed, we're trying to make it so that you can put a certain amount of money in every year, even as an individual.
我想只有一个捐赠者。所以如果你在收听这个节目，非常感谢你，不管你是谁。但我的意思是，这也是问题的一部分，我真的没有办法——至少我认为没有办法——去联系那个人并说：“嘿，你喜欢这个的什么地方？”我的意思是，你愿意为它投入资金，所以你的意见真的很重要，对吧？所以这种对话是不存在的，摩擦力实在太高了。所以我认为你正试图解决其中的一些问题。好吧，如果你和普通开发者交流，他们会为自己没有以某种方式支持开源而感到内疚。但事实是，要想知道如何支持你日常使用的 1,000 个软件包是非常困难的。所以确实，我们正努力让你能够每年投入一定金额的资金，哪怕你只是个个人。
But I think we should be encouraging these big fan companies to put their money where their mouths are with this stuff like they make a lot of money out of open source the open source ecosystem powers the internet more software and if somebody does open source yourself you know that you could spend a lot more time on it like i assume you made your tool because you wanted it and you want to work on it to a certain extent. And we want to make it so that it is possible for you to do so.
但我认为我们应该鼓励这些科技巨头公司在这个问题上说到做到。他们从开源中赚了很多钱，开源生态系统支撑了互联网和更多的软件。如果你自己做开源，你就知道你可以花更多的时间在上面——我假设你制作你的工具是因为你需要它，并且在某种程度上你想继续开发它。我们希望创造条件，让你能够做到这一点。
The whole impetus for it came from this library for iOS called PromiseKit that I made years ago. And at its peak, it was used by 100,000 apps. And so I was like, well, if every one of those apps
这一切的契机源于我多年前为 iOS 制作的一个名为 PromiseKit 的库。在它的全盛时期，它被 10 万个应用所使用。所以我当时就在想，如果这其中的每一个应用
gave me just $1 a year, I could afford to work on it full-time and all my other open source, take a bit of a salary hit overall, but then I could find some more open source to make. You don't need that much from everyone. You just need everyone to somehow be able to participate. And so that's where we're coming at with what we're doing.
每年只给我 1 美元，我就能承担得起全职开发它以及我所有的其他开源项目的费用，虽然总体薪资可能会受点打击，但接着我就能找到更多开源项目来制作了。你不需要每个人都给你那么多钱。你只需要每个人都能以某种方式参与进来。这就是我们看待我们所做事情的角度。
And we want to make it so successful that people at Facebook and Microsoft and Google and all these big companies, these talented developers who are basically wasting their time making algorithms that improve ad consumption, how much people participate with content, instead realize that they have a viable option to quit and work on an important piece of open source full time. I want all these people to quit i want facebook to seriously run out of developers and i have problems running the company because everyone
我们希望把它做得如此成功，以至于 Facebook、微软、谷歌和所有这些大公司的员工——那些基本上在浪费时间制作提高广告消费和人们对内容参与度的算法的才华横溢的开发者——能够意识到，他们有一个切实可行的选择，那就是辞职并全职从事重要的开源工作。我希望所有人都能辞职，我希望 Facebook 严肃地遭遇没有开发者的困境，并且因为每个人
has quit to do what is better for the entire open source ecosystem for the entire internet and not as humanity as a whole yeah i think that makes sense. I do feel like advertising completely changed the internet and just the software community. I feel like it radically changed. And I don't, you know, I'm not really educated enough on this to know why,
都辞职去从事对整个开源生态系统、对整个互联网、甚至对全人类更好的事情，而导致公司运营出现问题。是的，我觉得这说得通。我确实觉得广告彻底改变了互联网和整个软件社区。我觉得它发生了根本性的改变。我并不，你知道的，我没有接受过足够的教育来了解为什么，
to sort of the causal reasoning there and everything. But you're right. I think if we can sort of bring the economics back to some healthy place that i think we can cause sort of this explosion of because there's so many talented people all over the world who who uh wake up and and install linux for the first time and then all of a sudden they're on the vanguard of something um and and so if we can support those people, it would be fabulous.
了解其中的因果推理之类的东西。但你是对的。我想如果我们能把经济状况恢复到某种健康的状态，我想我们可以引发某种井喷，因为世界各地有那么多才华横溢的人，他们一觉醒来第一次安装了 Linux，然后突然之间他们就处于某种前沿……所以如果我们能支持这些人，那将是极好的。
Yeah, that's our mission. Cool. So yeah, we'll be releasing later this year, and we are hiring. But really, your listeners, one of the better things they can do is when we release, install it, try it out, and participate. There's going to be a huge open-source community
是的，这就是我们的使命。太棒了。所以，是的，我们将在今年晚些时候发布，我们在招人。但实际上，对于你的听众来说，他们能做的更好的事情之一就是，当我们发布时，安装它、试用它并参与进来。将会有一个庞大的开源社区
built up around it, just like Brew had, for people participating in making open source function. And we'll do the same kind of things we did for Brew and make it somewhere that is a great open source project to be a part of. And, well, we'll have token to facilitate contributions as well. Yeah, I mean, when people hear about cryptocurrency, they usually think about buying in, like buying a Bitcoin or buying a Ethereum coin or something like that. You don't have to be a millionaire to install T.
围绕它建立起来，就像 Brew 那样，供人们参与使开源发挥作用。我们将做和为 Brew 做过的一样的事情，把它变成一个非常棒的、让人想要参与其中的开源项目。而且，我们将拥有用于促进贡献的代币。是的，我的意思是，当人们听到加密货币时，他们通常会想到买入，比如买入比特币或以太坊币之类的。你不需要成为百万富翁才能安装 T。
I mean, it's not that kind of thing. You can install it. You can get started totally free. So it's not that kind of thing. You can install it. You can get started totally free. So it's completely free. It's basically a better packaging solution than probably what you're using. And over time, you'll start to see how you can use the crypto and the web-free parts for yourself and for the benefit of the entire open source ecosystem. So, yeah, it will definitely be worth checking out. Cool. All right.
我的意思是，它不是那种东西。你可以安装它。你可以完全免费开始使用。所以它不是那种东西。你可以安装它。你可以完全免费开始使用。所以它是完全免费的。它基本上是一个比你现在可能正在使用的更好的打包解决方案。随着时间的推移，你将开始看到如何为你自己以及为了整个开源生态系统的利益来使用加密货币和 Web3 部分。所以，是的，绝对值得一看。太好了。好的。
Well, when it's released, we will definitely post on our social media, Twitter and LinkedIn and all of that and get people aware of that. In the meantime, I'm sure you have a mailing list and those kinds of things. If people want to learn more about it and get ready, they can go to te.xyz. That's tea.xyz.
嗯，当它发布时，我们肯定会在我们的社交媒体、Twitter 和 LinkedIn 以及所有这些平台上发帖，让人们了解它。在此期间，我确信你有一个邮件列表和诸如此类的东西。如果人们想了解更多关于它的信息并做好准备，他们可以去 te.xyz。那是 tea.xyz。
And thank you so much, Max, for coming on the show. An absolutely fabulous episode, amazing. And we covered a topic that is really, really important that, shockingly, we had never covered before, even in the abstract. So we covered package managers, I think, beautifully. And I'm really excited about T. And I'll be the first one in line to try and get Eternal Terminal onto T whenever it's ready. Well, I hope you do that, Jason. All right. Sounds good. Thanks again, Max. And thanks, folks, out there for listening, supporting the show on Patreon. We really appreciate it. And we will catch everyone in two weeks. Bye-bye. Music by Aaron Farndeller. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license.
非常感谢你，马克斯（Max），来到节目中。绝对精彩的一期节目，太棒了。我们讨论了一个非常非常重要的话题，令人震惊的是，我们以前从未讨论过，甚至连抽象概念都没有涉及。所以我们把包管理器讨论得很透彻，我想。我对 T 感到非常兴奋。只要准备好了，我将第一个排队尝试把 Eternal Terminal 迁移到 T 上。嗯，我希望你这么做，杰森。好的。听起来不错。再次感谢马克斯。也感谢各位听众在 Patreon 上收听并支持本节目。我们非常感激。我们两周后见。再见。音乐由厄恩·法恩德勒（Aaron Farndeller）创作。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。
You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及混编、改编该作品，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式分享。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击转写文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。